Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim.
Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 140 von UKW.
Und wie in der letzten Ausgabe geht es heute wieder zum Jahresende um die Ukrainer.
Heute aber wieder mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Genau, nachdem ich in der letzten Sendung ja mit Enno gesprochen hatte, mit Enno Lenze.
Falls ihr die Sendung nicht gehört habt, kann ich euch die nochmal sehr ans Herz legen.
Ein sehr intensiver Bericht von der Front, da ja Enno regelmäßig in der Ukraine
unterwegs ist und sich einiges traut.
Ist das immer wieder sehr interessant zuzuhören, was da so seine Erfahrungen und Erkenntnisse sind.
Da lag der Fokus auf der letzten Sendung.
Deswegen wollen wir jetzt hier, wie es unsere selbst auferlegte Pflicht ist,
wieder mal für euch zusammenfassen, was ist eigentlich passiert.
Und wir blicken jetzt tatsächlich schon wieder auf drei Monate zurück.
Wir hatten uns ein bisschen Zeit gelassen.
Das hat immer so verschiedene Gründe. Hauptsächlich, dass man immer so das Gefühl
hat, es dreht sich im Kreis.
Das tut es auch oft so.
Aber jetzt auch gerade in der letzten Zeit sind wieder ein paar sehr interessante
Dinge passiert, sodass es jetzt einfach mal wieder Zeit wird.
Und ich denke jetzt auch mal so zum Jahresende ist es auch ganz gut,
mal so einen generellen Ausblick zu wagen.
Dauert ja auch nicht mehr so lange und dieser Krieg wird vier Jahre gedauert haben im Februar.
Das ist keine gute Nachricht, aber es ist einfach nur mal Realität.
Und deswegen schauen wir mal in die Ukraine und gucken mal was passiert ist,
Ja, letzte Sendung, wie gesagt, knapp drei Monate am 3.
Oktober haben wir die veröffentlicht.
Und ja, was ist seitdem passiert? Also was man auf jeden Fall erstmal sagen
muss ist, es passiert eines die ganze Zeit,
nämlich jeden Tag greift Russland mit einer schwindelerregenden Zahl von Raketen,
Drohnen aller Art das gesamte Gebiet der Ukraine an.
Also auch weit hinter der eigentlichen Frontlinie werden Städte angegriffen,
wird Infrastruktur angegriffen, Krankenhäuser, Kindergärten, Wohnungen, alles.
Regelmäßig gibt es immer wieder Berichte über absolut herzzerreißende Geschichten,
wo komplette Wohnblocks zusammengeschossen werden.
Viele Tote und Zivilisten, die davon betroffen sind vor allem.
Selten sind es also militärische Objekte. Damit will ich nicht sagen,
dass Russland nicht auch versucht, militärische Objekte anzugreifen.
Würden alle Raketen durchgehen, die geschickt werden, dann wäre es im Wesentlichen
und zum großen Teil zivile Objekte.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach zu sagen bei allen Angriffen, auf was wurde denn eigentlich gezielt.
Aber ja, definitiv.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach eine Kombination aus russischer Unfähigkeit oder
mangelnder Technik plus tatsächlich auch,
dass ein signifikanter Anteil meiner Meinung nach auch an ziviler Infrastruktur
oder einfach an Wohnungen oder Wohnblocks.
Als Terrorangriff auch gefahren wird. Aber teilweise,
Wissen wir ja auch, dass Russland auch gerne mal eines Territorium bombardiert,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Es ist ja jetzt auch wieder neulich passiert, dass sie irgendwie Bomben über
Belgorod abgeworfen haben.
Gut, aber das sind Fehlfunktionen. Aber es gibt jetzt gerade in letzter Zeit
dokumentierte Fälle, wo also dieser eine Wohnblock, ich habe es leider in der
Stadt vergessen, das war glaube ich irgendwo in Nibro.
Da sind irgendwie 30 Raketen in denselben Wohnblock eingeschlagen.
Da kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass das Zufall war.
Das kann kein Zufall sein, sondern das ist sozusagen gezielt ausgewählt und
getargetet worden und dementsprechend kann man, glaube ich, diese Behauptung stehen lassen.
Außerdem sind halt mittlerweile so gut wie alle Kraftwerke in der Ukraine nochmal
zusammengeschossen worden. Es gibt permanent Stromausfälle auch in der Hauptstadt
in Kiew, da hatte ja auch Enno schon drüber berichtet.
Ich weiß jetzt nichts Konkretes über die Heizungssituation, aber das dürfte
sich nicht sehr viel besser anfühlen.
Ja und das Problem ist vor allem, dass also in Anbetracht der Menge an Raketen,
die jede Nacht über die Ukraine hageln,
einfach nicht genug Abwehrsysteme bereitstehen und es gibt auch Berichte von
der ukrainischen Führung, also ich glaube Selenskyj hat das gesagt zuletzt,
dass manchen Luftabwehrsystemen, hat jetzt nicht gesagt welchen,
schlicht die Munition fehlt, also das ist einfach bei manchen Systemen.
Einfach nichts ist, was man losschicken kann.
Weiß jetzt keiner, ob das die aus Deutschland gestellten IRIS-Systeme sind,
ob das die Patriots sind, was auch immer. Ist auf jeden Fall nicht gut und kann
man nur hoffen, dass das sich in irgendeiner Form löst, dieses Problem.
Ja, aber an der Front sieht es dann fast besser aus.
Besser ist das nicht das richtige Wort.
Es gibt, abgesehen davon, dass Russland generell im gesamten Frontverlauf in
irgendeiner Form immer potenziell irgendwo reindrückt und Leute vorschickt,
gibt es so ein paar Hotspots.
Der auch in der letzten Sendung nochmal mehr besprochene Hotspot Pokrovsk.
Das ist also eine kleine Stadt oder Doppelstadt, Pokrovsk-Münorath,
die halt in den Fokus der Russen gekommen ist, nachdem diese Stronghold in Avdivka gefallen ist.
Da sind sie jetzt irgendwie auch schon seit über einem Jahr unterwegs,
diesen Ort einzunehmen.
Es ist ihnen jetzt in den letzten Monaten gelungen, in die Stadt vorzurücken und naja,
auch seit drei Monaten hören wir im Prinzip immer das Gleiche,
nämlich dass die Einnahme der Stadt jetzt sozusagen unmittelbar bevorsteht.
Und das kann man jetzt eigentlich auch sagen, bloß ob unmittelbar bedeutet,
morgen, nächste Woche, in einem Monat oder vielleicht doch auch erst wieder
in zwei Monaten, weiß keiner.
Wenn man auf die Karten schaut, die so veröffentlicht werden,
die ja immer belegen sollen, welche Partei welches Gebiet kontrolliert, kann man sagen.
Die Ukrainer weichen langsam zurück, aber mit der Betonung auf langsam.
Von daher ist Pokrov Smirnorat noch nicht komplett gefallen.
Andererseits braucht man sich auch relativ wenig Hoffnung machen,
dass sich dort das Blatt noch groß wenden wird. Und dazu sieht die Gesamtsituation
dort dann doch ein bisschen zu prekär aus.
Aber dieser Widerstand ist real und vor allem, und das darf man dabei nicht
vergessen, die Russen erleiden bei ihren Vorstößen enorme Verluste.
Also wirklich enorme Verluste. Da ist einfach der Einsatz an Menschenmaterial
der Russen kaum zu verstehen.
Ja, es ist sozusagen, da werden einfach Hunderte und Tausende pro Woche in den
sicheren Tod geschickt, einfach um wieder mal ein paar Meter nach vorne zu kommen.
Und das ist halt das ganze Prinzip des russischen Vorstoßes.
Das ist im Prinzip auch die Strategie der Ukrainer, die halt versuchen gegenzuhalten
mit einer generellen Taktik, die sagt,
wir tauschen im Zweifelsfall Gelände gegen Personal.
Das heißt, wir ziehen uns lieber zurück, als dass wir jetzt auf Biegen und Brechen
unsere Leute verheizen, nur um ein paar Meter zu halten.
Das ist nicht schön, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine Strategie,
die sicherstellt, dass die Russen eine Vielzahl mehr an Verlusten haben.
Und da sie ja rein numerisch auch immer noch die Überhand haben,
ist das überhaupt die Voraussetzung dafür, dass die Ukrainer überhaupt dagegen halten können.
Aber das gelingt ihnen insgesamt doch sehr gut, auch wenn die Verluste groß
sind. Und ja, das ist also die Situation in Pokrovsk.
Ähnliche Situationen haben wir, ja, ähnliches, also andere Hotspots,
sagen wir es mal so, andere Hotspots, also die Russen wollen halt den Donbass haben.
Das ist für sie sozusagen das, was sie da politisch auch angekündigt haben,
was sie irgendwie erreichen wollen jetzt erstmal.
Also eigentlich wollen sie natürlich die ganze Ukraine, aber jetzt sagen sie
erstmal, wir brauchen mal jetzt hier mal den Donetsk vollständig.
Da fehlt ihnen natürlich noch diese Stadtkette um Konstantinivka,
Kramatorsk, Sloviansk.
Das ist so ein Gürtel von drei größeren oder mittelgrößeren Städten und Kramatorsk
war schon immer das Einsatzzentrum der Ukrainer in Donetsk.
Also das ist quasi ihre Hauptstronghold, das ist mit Sicherheit die letzte Stadt,
die hier in irgendeiner Form stehen wird.
Da sind die Russen jetzt noch lange nicht vorgedrungen, haben aber auch ein
bisschen Boden gut gemacht.
Wenn wir von Boden gut machen reden, dann reden wir immer von einem Geschwindigkeitsvorstoß,
der einen Bruchteil der Geschwindigkeit einer Schnecke betrifft.
Also es ist so, eine Schnecke hätte in diesen vier Jahren der Ukraine schon
ein, zwei Mal komplett durchlaufen, aber die Russen sind irgendwie 30,
40 Kilometer weit gekommen und so ist halt diese Situation.
Auch sehr beunruhigend war die Situation um Kupiansk.
Wir erinnern uns, Kupiansk ist eine Stadt in dem Übergang zwischen Chakiv,
also im Oblast Chakiv und Luhansk.
Gehört also noch zu Kharkiv, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Bevor ich jetzt hier Quatsch erzähle, schnell mal einen Blick auf die Karte.
Ja, das liegt so genau an der Karte.
Genau, also es ist im östlichen Teil von Kharkiv.
Da fließt auch ein Fluss durch, das ist eine wichtige Eisenbahnlinie und das
war die Stadt, die sie bei ihrer Kharkiv-Offensive vor drei Jahren genommen haben in Windeseile.
Im letzten Jahr ist den Russen halt gelungen, langsam sich dieser Stadt zu nähern
und vor ein paar Monaten ist es ihnen auch gelungen, in die Stadt teilweise einzudringen.
Haben dann schon angefangen zu behaupten, die Stadt wäre jetzt komplett unter
russischer Kontrolle. Stimmte aber nicht.
Das Lustige ist, das behaupten sie auch immer noch, also Putin zumindest.
Allerdings ist die Situation seit zwei Wochen eine ganz andere.
Denn hier ist es den Ukrainern gelungen, durch einen taktischen Vorstoß auf
breiter Front das russische Einfallstor nach Kupiansk komplett abzuschneiden.
Und es gibt jetzt noch ein paar russische Truppen in der Stadt,
die aber komplett eingeschlossen zu sein scheinen und sodass davon auszugehen
ist, wenn es den Russen nicht in irgendeiner Form gelingt, hier das Blatt zu wenden,
dass also Kupiansk wieder komplett an die Ukraine fällt.
Das wäre auch sehr zu wünschen, denn wie schon erwähnt, ist das eben eine strategisch wichtige Stadt.
Die Nachbarstadt daneben, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das offiziell noch zu Kupiansk
gehört oder anders, heißt auf jeden Fall auf der anderen Seite des Ostkielflusses dort,
es heißt Kupiansk irgendwie anders, Wuslovy oder so.
Das ist das, wo das große Eisenbahnverteilerkreuz ist.
Das wird sicherlich derzeit nicht groß im Betrieb sein, aber das ist halt einfach
eine wichtige Infrastruktur, die die Ukraine weiter halten sollte und wahrscheinlich
auch noch eine Weile halten wird.
Also insgesamt ist die Situation dort so, dass die Russen drücken,
die Ukraine hält dagegen und im Falle von Kupiansk ist es ihnen gelungen,
den größten militärischen Erfolg der letzten Zeit auf dem Boden zu erzielen.
Und die Russen haben da also doch einige Probleme auch in ihrer Propaganda.
Es gibt so veröffentlichte Videos von, ja, wir sind jetzt hier in Kupiansk und
dann kommt natürlich gleich die Osin-Community und sagt, wo seid ihr?
Da schauen wir doch mal nach.
Gehen und lokalisieren dann diese Videos und stellen fest, ja,
okay, Kupiansk ist noch 20 Kilometer entfernt, ihr sitzt da jetzt hier in dem
Dorf, wo ihr schon seit drei Jahren rumsitzt.
Also euch glaubt sowieso keiner was.
Oder wie Georgi immer so schön sagt, wenn er wenn ein Russel das Maul aufmacht, dann ist es eine Lüge.
Ja, also im Moment kann man generell feststellen, die russischen Millblogger
sind nicht so gut gelaunt.
Also die haben gerade eher schlechte Laune aus den verschiedensten Gründen und
Kupiansk ist sozusagen einer der Gründe.
Und die Frage ist, wie viel weiß Putin tatsächlich?
Also ist er da wirklich im Bilde? Vermutlich schon.
Aber man weiß es nicht. Wenn natürlich alle Generäle um ihn herum das schönreden wollen und,
dann kann das tatsächlich sein, dass Putin einfach auch schlecht informiert ist an der Stelle.
Was natürlich noch peinlicher ist.
Ja, also der wird sich schon mit einer erkläglichen Zahl von Yes-Men umgeben haben.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu analysieren, wer da jetzt den Scheiß auch wirklich glaubt.
Aber ich meine, mit seiner ganzen Doktrin ist Putin so weit entrückt.
Er ist zwar ein knallharter Realist, was die politischen Deals betrifft,
aber insgesamt wirkt sein Verhalten eher verzweifelt.
Weil das, was er da tut, ist für sein Land nicht mehr gut.
Und man hat auch den Anschein, dass alles an die Front geworfen wird,
was dann verfügbar wird.
Das heißt, man hat nicht das Gefühl, da werden jetzt erstmal Reserven aufgebaut
oder dass man sich mal ein bisschen zurücknimmt und auf Verteidigung schaltet.
Und ja, vielleicht dann genug Kräfte auch.
In Reserve hat, um dann vielleicht mal einen größeren Vorstoß zu wagen.
Aber was so die Zahlen angeht, sieht das so aus, dass jeder neue verfügbare
Rekrut nach vorne geworfen wird.
Plus dann auch natürlich Truppen abgezogen werden im Inneren,
die zum Beispiel Flugplätze bewachen.
Aber da kommen wir dann hinterher noch draus zu sprechen, welche Folgen das
auch hat an anderen Stellen im Land.
Aber ja, das ist also bemerkenswert, dass Putin nicht mal auf die Idee gekommen
ist, nachdem die jetzt seit, ja,
bestimmt, weiß ich nicht, zwei, die letzten zwei Jahre irgendwie,
ja, an die Front werfen, was sie können und aber zwischen 800 und 1200 Leute,
verlieren jeden Tag, entweder verwundet oder getötet.
Also das heißt, es ist nach wie vor zwischen 25.000 und 30.000 an Verlusten, die die Russen haben.
Und ja, das sieht nicht so aus, als wenn sie da in der Lage wären,
größere Reserven aufzubauen.
Definitiv nicht und es gibt auch, da kommen wir auch noch zu Berichte,
dass sich die Situation der Rekrutierung auch nicht unbedingt verbessert.
Bevor wir das besprechen, lass uns mal schauen, was die Ukraine jetzt jenseits
der Frontaktivität noch so tut.
Also wir haben jetzt bisher quasi jetzt nur über die Frontlinie gesprochen,
aber die Angriffe finden ja nicht nur durch die Russen im Gebiet der Ukraine
statt, sondern mittlerweile, wie wir wissen, auch auf dem Gebiet Russlands durch die Ukraine statt.
Und da hat sich halt in den letzten drei Monaten eine Taktik vor allem ganz deutlich gezeigt.
Die Ukraine geht jetzt hart, aber richtig hart auf die Infrastruktur Russlands,
die erforderlich ist, um Öl zu fördern, Öl zu transportieren,
Öl in andere Produkte zu raffinieren.
Und diese Produkte, also entweder Rohöl oder auch Benzin, Diesel,
was auch immer, sonstige Produkte zu exportieren.
Mit anderen Worten, die vollständige Wirtschaftskette der Russen,
die ja im Wesentlichen auf der Förderung von Öl basiert, wird durch die Ukraine geschwächt.
Und zwar dadurch, dass sie eben all diese ganzen Produktionsorte.
Außer jetzt Ölförderungsanlagen in Sibirien, also alles was in ihrer Reichweite
ist, aber das ist halt nicht wenig, aktiv angreifen.
Das waren vor allem jetzt erstmal diese ganzen Ölraffinerien,
die recht verwundbar sind, weil wenn man es schafft, diese zentrale Destillationstechnik
zum Beispiel zu zerstören,
dann sind auch diese riesigen Gelände weitgehend außer Betrieb gesetzt,
weil das halt einfach so ein Flaschenhals in der Produktion ist.
Genauso sind Angriffe auf benachbarte Trafformatoren, Substationen für die Stromverteilung
in den Gebieten dann auch teilweise sehr effizient.
Einerseits, weil sie dann eben auch die Prozesse in der Fabrik nicht mehr erlauben,
die weiter zu betreiben.
Teilweise betrifft das dann aber auch so die Zulieferung über die Bahn.
Und ja, das war halt am Anfang des Jahres war das so ein Ab und Zu,
es wurde auch ab und zu mal ausgesetzt, immer so aus politischen Gründen,
weil USA sich irgendwie gemeldet haben, man sich in irgendeinem angeblichen
Friedensprozess wählte, etc. Da kommen wir auch noch drauf zu.
Aber mittlerweile scheint die Ukraine hier keine Fax mehr zu geben und haut
einfach auf alles drauf, was weil es zwar nicht auf den Bäumen ist und da kann
halt gar nichts auf die Bäume klettern.
Dementsprechend werden fast täglich Ölraffinerien angegriffen oder auch Gaskraftwerke,
oder Gasproduktionsanlagen und,
Pipelines werden angegriffen, Pumpstationen von Pipelines werden angegriffen,
teilweise eben mit Raketenangriffen, Drohnenangriffen oder auch mit gezielten Sabotageakten.
Da gab es zum Beispiel direkt vor Moskau einen Angriff mit Sprengsätzen,
wo irgendwelche ukrainischen Spezialtrupps es geschafft haben,
so eine Pipeline, die da so einen Graben, so einen größeren Graben wie so eine
Brücke überbrückt hat, dort Sprengsätze anzusetzen, das auch noch zu filmen und so.
Also solche Sachen. Es werden chemische Fabriken und auch Fabriken der Elektronikproduktion,
also alles was in irgendeiner Form in dieser Kriegsproduktion mit drin ist,
speziell die halt so Waffenmaterial,
Munitionsmaterial herstellen etc.
Wird alles angegriffen, Schahed, Produktionsfabriken und das alles eben mit
Drohnen oder teilweise auch gar nicht mal durch die Ukrainer selbst,
sondern vielleicht auch unterstützt durch die Ukraine, gibt es halt auch so
ein paar bekennende Partisanengruppen, die in Russland verschiedene Sabotageakte ausführen.
Da bezieht sich das aber dann meistens auf die Bahndinien, wobei auch es Drohnenangriffe
von der Ukraine gibt auf Züge, auf fahrende Züge,
da werden also so Öltransporte auf Zügen, werden in der Fahrt angegriffen,
dann fängt ein Wagen an zu brennen oder man geht glaube ich erstmal auf die
Lok und wenn der Zug steht, dann wird sozusagen Stück für Stück auch noch der Rest zerraut.
Und also das findet halt die ganze Zeit alles schon statt und man kann sagen,
das ist relativ erfolgreich. Die Schätzungen darüber, wie weit die Ölproduktion
so zurückgegangen ist, die sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Dinge werden ja auch teilweise repariert, aber das geht halt auch alles nicht so schnell.
Ich weiß nicht, was du zuletzt gehört hast, so 30 Prozent der Produktionskapazität
ist definitiv eingeschränkt, vielleicht ist es auch schon mehr.
Ja, wie gesagt, schwer zu sagen. Also Russen selber reden, glaube ich, von 5 Prozent oder so.
Oh, na dann sind es wahrscheinlich 50.
Ja, aber so, also 15 bis 20 Prozent könnten realistisch sein, denke ich mal.
Mein Interessant ist, dass jetzt seit einigen Wochen keine Berichte mehr über
lange Schlangen an Tankstellen gibt.
Es scheint so, dass sie das zumindest irgendwie hingekriegt haben.
Vermutlich entweder dann Reserven oder dann Auslandsimporte aus Belarus oder
so besser verteilt kriegen.
Oder dass eben auch unterdrückt wird, wenn das passiert.
Oder sie vielleicht einfach, also viele Tankstellen haben auch einfach zugemacht.
So, dann gibt es auch keine Schlangen.
Richtig.
Und dann haben sie vielleicht, ja, keine Ahnung, dann die andere Hälfte wird
dann jetzt so beliefert, dass zumindest keine gigantischen Schlangen mehr entstehen.
Und dann passieren natürlich auch immer so Effekte, dass die Leute hamstern.
Und das kann sein, dass dann auch, sagen, als es dann irgendwann mal kurz geknappt
wurde, haben die Leute halt alle angefangen zu hamstern und jetzt haben sie erstmal,
volle Tanks. Das kann auch sein.
Es kann vor allem aber auch sein, dass diese Inlandsversorgung auf Kosten der Exporte geht.
Dass einfach nicht mehr so viel exportiert wird. Da kommen wir auch gleich noch dazu.
Denn dort ist es ja dann auch schwieriger geworden, dass durchzuführen.
Und ich meine, genaue Berichte gibt es jetzt nicht,
was so die Schäden angeht, die dadurch entstehen, dass nicht mehr alles Öl verarbeitet
oder abgenommen werden kann.
Weil ich hatte mir dann mal angeschaut, was denn so für Probleme entstehen,
wenn du so eine Ölquelle einfach abdrehst.
Du kannst wohl zwei bis drei Tage oder so, ist so ein Zeitraum,
der jetzt noch unproblematisch ist.
Aber wenn das Öl jetzt länger als ein paar Tage steht, gerade vor allem in Sibirien,
da wo es etwas kälter ist, bilden sich einfach Wachstropfen.
Und man kriegt das dann in den Ölquellen wohl teilweise auch nicht wieder verflüssigt, weil,
es gibt keine Heizdrähte oder so jetzt in der Ölquelle,
mit denen man das jetzt alles verflüssigen könnte, das heißt wenn sich das wenn
das aufhört zu fließen, wenn das halt verwachst ist, so dann hilft halt nur neu bohren.
Musst du halt nochmal mit Bohrequipment anrücken und einfach diesen Wachspropf
raus bohren, was natürlich ja, nicht gut ist.
Dann, was dann auch passiert, je nachdem wo das ist, dieses Rohöl enthält halt
auch Wasser und je nachdem, wie hoch der Wasseranteil ist,
ja, wird das dann zu Schäden, gerade an Pumpen und.
Sperre-Hähnen, sag ich mal, und so weiter, wenn der Fluss da zum Stillstand
kommt, einfach weil sich das Wasser halt auch ausdehnt, einfach wenn es gefriert.
Und wir sagen, der Punkt ist,
und das scheint die Ukraine strategisch tatsächlich gemacht zu haben,
wenn einerseits die Raffineriekapazität reduziert wird und andererseits,
dann müsste die Alternative mehr zu exportieren,
um die Ölquellen am Laufen zu halten.
Oder wenn jetzt die Exporte beeinträchtigt werden, dann kannst du halt intern
einfach mehr verarbeiten.
Oder mehr zwischenspeichern.
Aber auch die Speicher werden ja angegriffen.
Genau, also dadurch, dass die Ukraine jetzt sowohl Speicherer als auch Raffinerien
als auch dann Pipelines und Tanker angreift, kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass das eben dann upstream auch zu weiteren Schäden führt, weil die Ölquellen einfach nicht mehr, ja,
Weil kein Öl mehr fließt, überall.
Also genaue Berichte darüber oder Zahlen gibt es nicht, aber eigentlich der
Logik nach, das Öl muss ja irgendwo hin.
Und ich habe jetzt auch nicht gehört, dass sie jetzt dort größere Ölseen anlegen oder so in Sibirien.
Ja, das ist unklar. Ich meine, ein Stück weit können sie sicherlich ihre Quellen
den Druck reduzieren, aber sie müssen es halt in irgendeiner Form noch fließen lassen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, um wie viel Prozent man diesen Flow zurückfahren kann,
ohne dass es zu diesen Schäden kommt.
So oder so ist einfach diese Das gesamte Management des Produktionsprozesses
ist nachhaltig gestört und ändert sich gegebenenfalls auch täglich in der Verteilung.
Russland ist groß, Russland hat sehr viele Facilities, das darf man nicht unterschätzen,
trotz alledem, das hilft alles überhaupt nicht.
Dazu kommt ja, dass jetzt auch noch die Ölplattformen, Ölförderungsplattformen
im Kaspischen Meer angegriffen wurden.
Das ist jetzt neu. Also bisher hatten wir das Kaspische Meer als Battleground
eigentlich gar nicht, abgesehen davon, dass die Russen ab und zu mal aus Panik
aserbaidschanische Flugzeuge abgeschossen haben.
Ja, und sie haben halt auch von Schiffen aus dem kaspischen Meer aus Cruise
Missiles abgeschossen auf die Ukraine.
Also das sozusagen, insofern war das schon auch Teil, sag ich mal,
mit den Langstrecken Cruise Missiles, die da haben.
Da wurden auch eben vom kaspischen Meer aus dann Angriffe mit koordiniert.
Weil, ich meine, Russland mittlerweile schickt ja pro Angriff zwischen 500 und 800 Flugkörper los.
Großteil davon jetzt Schahits oder Unterschall-Cruise-Missiles im Prinzip oder
billige Drohnen und ein paar Dutzend daneben auch ballistische Raketen sind dann da reingemischt,
meistens in so einen Schlag.
Aber die Ukraine hat jetzt auch, sage ich deutlich, die 500 Flugkörperschwelle
pro Angriff überschritten.
Also Russen feuern doch noch ein bisschen mehr, was die Anzahl der Flugkörper
angeht und wahrscheinlich auch die Größe.
Aber die Ukraine ist mittlerweile nah dran, also du hast das Gefühl,
so ungefähr zwei Drittel der Stückzahlen,
kommt jetzt auf zwei Drittel der Stückzahlen wie die Russen bei jetzt von Drohnen
und Flugkörpern, ballistischen Raketen, also was dann so pro Nacht losgeschickt wird.
Und ja, die russische, wie viel davon die russische Flugabwehr tatsächlich abfängt,
wissen wir nicht, da haben wir bessere Zahlen immer aus der umgekehrten Seite,
wo es der Ukraine immer noch gelingt, immer zwischen 70 und 95 Prozent,
runterzuholen, aber es kommen dann eben auch jedes Mal Dutzende von Drohnen
kommen durch oder Raketen.
Genau. Was man jetzt auch noch hinzufügen muss, haben wir schon angedeutet,
dass es ein paar sehr erfolgreiche und die Situation ist noch ongoing,
sehr erfolgreiche Angriffe auf die Exporthäfen vor allem im Schwarzen Meer und
im Asowschen Meer gegeben hat.
Russland hat ja vor allem seinen großen Hafen, Novorossist, das ist teilweise
zivil, teilweise militärisch.
Dann gab es noch Tuapse, weiter noch im Osten, das ist ein reines Öl-Terminal.
Dann gab es auf der Krim Fodosia auch noch einen mittelgroßen Versorgungshafen,
wo vor allem das Öl hingebracht und zwischengespeichert wird,
um das dann auf der Krim zu nutzen.
Öl oder Öl wahrscheinlich nicht, sondern im Wesentlichen dann Dieselbenzin.
All diese ganzen Orte wurden mehr oder weniger erfolgreich von der Ukraine angegriffen
und dabei wurde also signifikant Infrastruktur zerstört.
Also in Tuapse gab es mehrere Angriffe und das ist halt so, dass in diesen Häfen
sind so große Pipelines,
die dann in spezielle Anlegerstege gehen, wo dann die Öltanker anlegen und dort
dann halt direkt betankt werden.
Und das war quasi das Ziel mehrerer Angriffe.
Es ist ein bisschen unklar, wie erfolgreich das im Einzelnen war,
weil es teilweise dann doch noch Exportbetrieb gab, obwohl da gerade Angriffe
gelaufen sind, aber die Zerstörungen waren schon immens.
Speziell in Novorossisk, wo die Ukraine jetzt nicht nur die eigentliche Ölverladestruktur
angegriffen hat, sondern vorher auch so eine komplette verhältnismäßig moderne
S-400-Batterie weggehauen hat.
Also die Launcher und das Radar und so weiter, was diesen Hafen beschützt hat,
wurde dabei auch noch angegriffen.
Die ganzen Tanks in Fodosia auf der Krim waren weitgehend zerstört.
Also das sind alles so, ich weiß nicht, man kann es gar nicht Nadelstiche nennen,
es sind eigentlich mehr so einzelne Hammerschläge, die dort ausgeübt werden
und es ist ein bisschen unklar, wie schnell Russland hier mit Reparaturen und
Workarounds arbeiten kann,
um in irgendeiner Form darüber noch verfügen zu können über diese Infrastruktur.
Gut, was da am Boden passiert jetzt an diesen Terminals.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass zwar die Hauptfüllanlagen beschädigt oder zerstört sind,
aber dass sie dann halt einfach mit irgendwelchen Schläuchen
und Pumpen auf irgendwelchen
Lastern einfach improvisieren und dann halt einfach einen Schlauch von einem
Tanklaster nehmen und irgendeine Pumpe und dann die Schiffe auf diese Art und Weise füllen, was...
Vermutlich viel, viel länger dauert und super gefährlich ist.
Aber das wäre meine Vermutung oder Erklärung, warum dort nach Angriffen tatsächlich
auch Aktivität stattfand.
Und es gibt dann auch noch irgendwelche Nebenpiers.
Also viele dieser Anlagen sind etwas zerklüftet und haben halt eventuell noch
ältere Infrastruktur oder Infrastruktur für kleine Tanker oder für große oder
vom Umladen von einem Tanker in den anderen und so.
Und das werden sie irgendwie genutzt haben, vermute ich mal.
Aber ja, hilfreich ist das sicherlich nicht.
Und es dann eben auch zu sehen war, dass dann eben Tanker teilweise ausweichen
mussten und anderswo dann angelegt haben, wo sie normalerweise nicht anliegen.
Genau, und zum Tankern kommen wir gleich. Was man auch noch zur Kenntnis nehmen
sollte, Tuapse vor allem ist ein wichtiger Ölhafen nicht nur für Russland,
sondern quasi als Untermieter versorgt auch Kasachstan seine Kunden mit seinem
Öl über eine Pipeline, die durch Russland läuft und dort halt normalerweise
eben auch auf Tanker geladen wird.
Mit anderen Worten, auch Kasachstan ist jetzt hier betroffen.
Die sind ja so ein bisschen landlocked, also sind zwar da irgendwie am Kaspischen
Meer, aber die haben halt irgendwie keine...
Und keine spezielle Infrastruktur außerhalb dieser Pipeline,
die jetzt in der Lage wäre, ihre großen Ölexporte aufrechtzuerhalten.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd für Kasachstan, zumal sich Kasachstan jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt gerade als russische Allianz gebärdet hat, sondern eigentlich eine
relativ große Distanz zu Putin gehalten hat im Vergleich zu wie das früher mal war.
Ja, aber das ist dann halt einfach ein Fallout, da müssen sie sich dann was
anderes einfallen lassen.
Gehen wir nochmal auf diese Shadow Fleet, über die so viel gesprochen wurde
und die jetzt auch von der Ukraine nochmal besonders bekämpft wird.
Und vielleicht erstmal ganz gut so ein bisschen zu erklären,
wie denn das eigentlich überhaupt so funktioniert.
Weil das ist ja so ein Begriff, der jetzt seit längerem in der Berichterstattung
im Raum ist, Shadow Fleet, die russische Shadow Fleet.
Ja, warum gibt es die denn überhaupt? Also dieses ganze Öltanker-Business, das globale.
Das funktioniert nur teilweise so, dass den ölexportierenden Ländern die Flotte,
die halt das Öl transportiert, selbst gehört.
Generell ist das ja auf der offenen See so eine Sache, unter welcher Flagge
sind die unterwegs, wem gehören die?
Dann gibt es da so internationale Verbünde und teilweise ist es sehr schwierig
überhaupt nachzuvollziehen, wem jetzt irgendwas gehört,
beziehungsweise da ist so eine ganze Kaskade von Vernetzungsketten und viele
sind irgendwie in Panama registriert oder in Afrika und so weiter.
Alles sehr unübersichtlich. Das Öltanker-Business selber ist dann nochmal ganz speziell.
Es gab ja über die Jahrzehnte so ein enormes Wachstum. Öltanker wurden immer
größer, immer größer, immer größer, bis dann irgendwie die totalen Supertanker gebaut wurden.
Ja, also 200 Meter lang, was weiß ich, wie groß.
Das fand dann allerdings vor einiger Zeit sein Ende.
Mittlerweile werden die nicht mehr größer, weil das sich dann irgendwann gar
nicht mehr so richtig gelohnt hat.
Allerdings ein paar der letzten großen Tanker, die dann zwar gar nicht mehr
fuhren, wurden dann trotzdem noch weiterverwendet und zwar so als Ölspeicher on the sea.
Das heißt, die funktionieren dann so, dass immer wenn der Ölpreis sinkt,
kaufen diese Betreiber dieser Schiffe Öl, tanken das in ihren großen Tanker
rein und warten, bis der Preis wieder steigt.
Und wenn dann sozusagen die Nachfrage groß ist, dann verkaufen sie eben dieses
dort gelagerte Öl zu einem entsprechenden Mehrpreis.
Ja.
Aber grundsätzlich gibt es halt einfach diesen Trend, dass auch die großen Ölproduktionsfirmen
keine eigenen Tankerflotten mehr unterhalten.
Das hat viel auch mit der Exxon Valdez zu tun, die ja mal gestrandet ist.
Das war also einfach ein riesiges Problem, dass diese Katastrophe über den Namen
des Schiffes, die Firma damit so direkt verbunden war.
Deswegen hat man es heute eher mit einer Flotte zu tun von kleineren privat
betriebenen Öltankern, die also teilweise auch wirklich nur ein Schiff pro Betreiber haben.
Das sind also gar nicht diese großen Agglomerationen, wie man das jetzt aus
dem Container-Business kennt,
sondern das ist eigentlich eher so eine Free-Floating-Flotte von kleinen privaten
Betreibern, mehr so Taxi-Unternehmen eigentlich für Öl.
Das heißt, man hat dadurch sehr viel On-Demand-Kapazität, die man jederzeit umrauten kann.
Ja, wobei, ja, also von der Größe her sind es, glaube ich, eher,
du sagst, es ist 200 Meter.
Ich glaube, gehen so eher bis 400 Meter, so 350, 380 Meter und sind dann so
200.000 Tonnen, glaube ich.
Bei Tonnage mit Schiffen ist auch nochmal so ein spezielles Ding,
weil das nicht unbedingt jetzt Gewicht bezeichnet, sondern auch Volumen sozusagen,
also Tonnage, je nachdem, welche Art von Tonnage man da nimmt,
aber ja, egal. Aber jedenfalls...
Was ich dann gehört habe, ist, dass es insgesamt etwa sich um 1000 Schiffe handelt,
die jetzt zu dieser Shadow Fleet, die für Russland aktiv ist, gehören.
Wobei etwa die Hälfte davon, also 500 Schiffe,
tatsächlich im russischen Besitz sind und die anderen 500 sich aus einer Gruppe
von Dutzenden oder Hunderten Betreibern rekrutieren,
die dann einfach das auf sich nehmen und dann eben nicht nur mit russischem Öl,
sondern generell dann gerne mit Sanktionsöl.
Also Iran spielt dort eine Rolle, Venezuela genauso, wo ja auch zwei Tanker
jetzt von den USA hops genommen wurden.
Wobei der erste Tanker, ich meine, das ist auch interessant,
da kann man sagen, waren die USA sogar rechtlich wahrscheinlich im Reinen,
weil das erste Schiff, was sie hochgenommen hatten, hatte keine valide Registry.
Also das war sozusagen nirgendwo registriert, nirgendwo versichert,
wurde nirgendwo inspiziert.
Es gab auch entsprechende Gerichtsbeschlüsse, die halt die Beschlagnahme dieses
Schiffes erlaubt haben.
Und es gibt da auch in dem Sinne keinen Staat unbedingt,
der sich da jetzt wehren kann, wobei Venezuela jetzt sagen könnte,
okay, aber hier unser Öl und aber bei dem ersten Tanker, der da.
Der da gekapert wurde oder beschlagnahmt wurde, ist wahrscheinlich rechtlich okay.
Der zweite Tanker jetzt allerdings war ein ganz anderes Ding.
Der war in Panama registriert und war gültig versichert und so.
Und war jetzt, wenn man jetzt auch von Shadowfleet oder Illegalität,
ist das auch ein Spektrum von Schiffen,
die gelegentlich mal heiße Ware befördern,
aber ansonsten korrekt versichert sind und korrekt registriert sind,
bis hin eben zu solchen Schiffen,
die einfach, man so will,
nicht angemeldet sind.
Und dementsprechend auch keinerlei Schutz genießen durch die entsprechenden
internationalen Gesetze.
Also sagen sicher bist du nur, wenn du irgendwo registriert wirst.
Ansonsten kann im Prinzip jede Marine dir das Schiff wegnehmen.
Ohne dass du dich beschweren kannst.
Das ist halt wie wenn du mit einem nicht angemeldeten Auto gestohlenes Gut transportierst, so ungefähr.
Ja, stellt man sich die Frage, warum setzen sich eigentlich viele diesem Risiko aus?
Und ja, die Antwort ist, es ist wohl ein absolutes Superbusiness.
Dadurch, dass nicht mehr so viele Öltanker gebaut werden, sind sogar gebrauchte
Öltanker in High Demand, werden also teilweise mit Töten,
Gewinn weiterverkauft und das gilt auch für sehr alte Tanker.
Und überhaupt wird die gesamte Tankerflotte der Welt im Schnitt immer älter.
Und jetzt gab es ja verschiedene rechtliche Maßnahmen und Drucksanktionen,
die ausgerufen wurden von der EU und auch von den USA.
Um diese Shadowfleet der da Russen irgendwie klein zu halten.
Und das hat wohl jetzt erstmal dazu geführt, dass zum Beispiel Panama,
das ist glaube ich die größte Schiffregistrie der Welt, überhaupt gar keine
Tanker mehr registriert,
die älter als 15 Jahre alt sind.
Es gibt jetzt auch so eine neue Database, eine sogenannte Risk Database in Liberia.
Liberia ist ja auch eine ganz große und wichtige Registry für Schiffe weltweit.
Darüber gibt es dann überhaupt die erste Mal so einen zentralen Exchange Point,
wo man sich darüber informieren kann, welches Schiff Under Investigation ist.
Das ist also sozusagen so eine Information, die jetzt so readily noch nicht
verfügbar war in letzter Zeit. Das ändert sich jetzt eben auch.
Und um denen zu entgehen, haben natürlich jetzt viele Tanker so Umgehungsstrategien,
also viele Tankerbetreiber für Umgehungsstrategien, also vor allem Russland.
Das führt dann dazu, dass mit registrierten Schiffen Öl irgendwo abgeholt wird,
aber dann wird es irgendwie auf dem Meer oder sonst irgendwo in irgendwelchen
Häfen in andere Tanker dann umgepumpt, die es dann woanders hinbringen.
Also das ist eine beliebte Technik.
Teilweise haben die dann auch keine gültigen Versicherungen,
weil ja auch die Versicherungsunternehmen Druck bekommen haben, vor allem von der EU.
Da sieht es dann eben so aus, dass sie eben keine Versicherung abgeben dürfen
für Öltanker, wo der Ölpreis unter über 60 Dollar liegt und solche Geschichten
und verschiedene andere Maßnahmen auch.
Ja, Russland hat dann irgendwie versucht, so Fake-Registries zu verwenden,
so die zu tun, als wäre ein Schiff irgendwo registriert.
Dann kommen dann so großartige Länder wie Laos oder Eswatini.
Weißt du, wo Eswatini ist?
Nee.
Früher hieß das mal Swaziland, das ist so diese Enklave in Südafrika.
Naja, also das ist auf jeden Fall so die Situation und daraus registriert sich
also diese Shadow Fleet.
Mit anderen Worten, man hat jetzt versucht über rechtliche und Registrierungs-
und Versicherungsmaßnahmen in irgendeiner Form Schiffe davon abzuhalten,
mit Russland Geschäfte zu machen, da hinzufahren, Öl zu holen und weiter zu reichen.
Das war aber nur eingeschränkt erfolgreich. Also war jetzt überhaupt nicht erfolgreich,
aber da war immer noch eine ganze Menge Betrieb.
Brüsseland ist es immer noch gelungen, so Öl nach China, nach Indien und wer
sonst noch bereit war, das abzunehmen, zu liefern.
Allerdings haben auch mittlerweile durch die gesteigerten US-Sanktionen,
wo dann sozusagen auch so Secondary Intermediates bestraft werden können,
haben jetzt auch schon diverse Länder das auch unterlassen,
weil sie eben jetzt wiederum befürchten mussten, dort durch sekundäre Bestrafungen betroffen zu sein.
Aber ja, die Ukraine hat gesagt, reicht uns nicht.
Da muss irgendwie mehr passieren. Es gibt immer noch genug Schiffe, die das machen.
Wir gehen jetzt hier mal aufs Ganze und wir greifen jetzt diese Tanker einfach direkt an.
Und das haben sie dann getan. Das fing dann an im Schwarzen Meer.
Vor ein paar Wochen haben sie zwei Tanker am selben Tag, ich glaube auch räumlich
in etwa im selben Bereich.
Angegriffen und zwar mit ihren Marine Drones, also mit diesen Tankern.
Über Wasser, Booten, die halt ferngesteuert, unterschiedlich ausgerüstet sind.
Also da gibt es halt die klassischen Kamikaze, die also die Schiffe rammen und
dann explodieren, die eine relativ große Payload haben.
Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher. Ich glaube, diese beiden wurden nur
durch solche Marine Drones angegriffen.
Es gibt ja auch noch die Variante, dass mit den Marine Drones wiederum Quadcopter
gestartet werden, die dann wiederum selber reingehen.
Aber das Ziel war jetzt hier primär immer das Heck dieser Schiffe.
Und man muss auch gleich mal dazu sagen, bisher war es bei all diesen angegriffenen
Tankern, kam ja da noch ein paar mehr, so, dass die leer waren.
Also jetzt nicht leer geputzt, aber die haben sozusagen ihre eigentliche Ölladung,
sollten die erst erhalten. Die waren auf dem Weg zu einem russischen Hafen und dementsprechend leer.
Und wurden dann aber von diesen Marine-Drohnen von der Ukraine außer Gefecht gesetzt.
Da gab es also diverse Explosionen, gibt es Videos dazu.
Und wo dann genau die Beschädigung war, kann man nicht genau sagen,
aber wenn du halt so die Schiffsschraube diesen Bereich angreifst, dann ist es relativ,
easy, so ein Schiff erstmal außer Betrieb zu nehmen und das führte dann auch
dazu, dass das genau passiert ist, das heißt die Schiffe waren dann,
Manövrierunfähig sind aber nicht gesunken.
Generell nur um sozusagen die finanziellen Dimensionen noch mal kurz zu beleuchten.
Also das Öl an Bord eines Tankers ist so zwischen 100 und 200 Millionen US-Dollar wert. und vollgetankt.
Also die kleinsten Aframax, irgendwie 50 Millionen und die richtig großen ULCCs,
von denen es nicht viel gibt.
Die haben so drei bis vier Millionen Barrel und das geht dann bis zu 300 Millionen
Dollar hoch, der Wert des Öls sozusagen.
Aber die meisten sind eben VLCCs, haben so zwei Millionen Barrel ungefähr,
die so je nach Ölpreis natürlich so um die 150 Millionen wert sind.
Und so ein Tanker selber, so ein VLCC, kostet so um die 100 Millionen Dollar.
Das heißt, generell ist das Öl mehr wert als der Tanker oder in derselben Größenordnung etwa.
Und wenn man jetzt weiß, also jetzt haben wir auch aktuell diese Situation,
dass der Ölpreis so ungefähr bei 60 Dollar pro Barrel liegt und Russland jetzt
gezwungen ist, sein Öl wegen des Risikos so für 30 Dollar pro Barrel.
Anzubieten.
So, das heißt, ja,
Und ja, dass man quasi, wenn man das dann,
gut, man wird jetzt nicht es zum normalen Preis verkaufen können,
aber wenn man selbst, wenn man nur, ich sag mal jetzt 10 oder 20 Dollar pro Barrel,
dann sind das zwischen 20 und 40 Millionen US-Dollar, die man verdienen kann
mit so einem Tankertrip.
So
Und ja, wie gesagt, die älteren Tanker sind auch ungefähr in der größten Ordnung
wahrscheinlich zu haben,
so um die 50 Millionen oder so.
Das heißt, wenn man drei oder vier Trips macht mit so einem Tanker unter aktuellen Bedingungen,
dann hat man schon mal das Geld für den Tanker raus.
Also ich würde sagen, es ist ein relativ lukratives Geschäft und ist jetzt eher
auf eine Art lukrativer geworden, aber auch gefährlicher durch die ganzen Maßnahmen,
sodass Russland gezwungen ist,
quasi jetzt die Leute zu ködern mit 30, 40 Millionen Gewinn pro Tankertrip und
haben trotzdem Schwierigkeiten.
Dann jetzt Crew zu finden oder Eigner zu finden, die jetzt bereit sind aktuell
das für weniger zu machen, sagen wir es mal so.
Genau, weil es ist ja jetzt nicht bei diesen beiden Schiffen geblieben,
also das war jetzt nicht die einzige Aktion, sondern innerhalb kürzester Zeit
gab es dann noch einen nicht ganz aufgeklärten,
Angriff in Senegal, vor Senegal, dann hat die Ukraine direkt mit.
FPV-Drohens, also mit ihren FP1-Drohnen, glaube ich, auf die kommen wir noch
zu sprechen, ein Schiff im Mittelmeer angegriffen.
Für die galt immer wieder, die waren leer und waren sozusagen aber bekannt,
dass sie eben bei den Russen mal zum Einsatz gekommen sind, dass sie also zu
dieser Shadowfleet gehören.
Und zuletzt gab es dann auch noch einen Angriff auf so einen Binnentanker,
der eher für die Flüsse ausgelegt ist in Rostov-on-Don, was ja ans Asowsche Meer grenzt.
Den haben sie dann direkt im Hafen mit einer Drohne getroffen.
Der ist auch gesunken und versperrt jetzt auch noch dieses Terminal.
Also den müssen sie da erstmal gehoben und weggeschleppt bekommen,
bevor sie dieses Terminal wieder benutzen können.
Und ja, in der Summe kann man einfach sagen, die Ukraine hat den großen Stinkefinger
rausgeholt und hat gesagt,
wenn ihr für die Russen Öl transportiert oder Benzin oder was auch immer oder
auch Gas, dann seid ihr ein Target.
Und ihr seid das nicht nur im Schwarzen Meer oder im Asowschen Meer oder im
Kaspischen Meer oder sonst irgendwo so, sondern auch im Mittelmeer und auch
im Atlantik und wir kriegen euch überall.
Und das hat natürlich jetzt das Risiko extrem erhöht,
weil trotz der von dir schon genannten potenziellen Verdienste,
die hier erzielt werden können durch das hohe Risiko, lassen die sich natürlich
das Risiko auch bezahlen.
Aber die Kosten steigen, weil erstens natürlich die Versicherung immer teurer
wird, weil die Versicherung sagt so, wo fahrt ihr hin?
Habt ihr sie noch alle? Oder generell jetzt, ach ihr wollt jetzt hier irgendwie
mit den Russen irgendwo langfahren?
So, nö, machen wir nicht und wenn, dann kostet das halt mehr.
Und dadurch, dass natürlich jetzt die Ukraine auch so mit, hast du gesagt FP1-Drohnen?
Ne, stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das Ding im Mittelmeer haben sie mit diesen Bomber-Drohnen gemacht,
also mit Quadrocopters, die einfach,
Sprengsätze abgeworfen haben und das Schiff sozusagen von oben direkt beschossen
haben und da kriegt natürlich dann auch die Crew das Muffensausen und lässt
sich das dann vielleicht auch nicht mehr einfach teurer bezahlen,
sondern die sagen dann halt einfach so,
ja okay, Geld können wir auch woanders verdienen.
Vielleicht jetzt nicht ganz so viel, aber dann werde ich nicht gleich noch von
den Ukrainern bombardiert. Das brauche ich jetzt nicht haben.
Und man sieht jetzt wohl auch schon die ersten Tanker.
Die, also jetzt konkret die Unternehmen, die halt schon betroffen waren,
aber ich würde mal sagen, ein paar andere werden sich das jetzt auch schon überlegen.
Wir hatten die Zahl ja vorhin schon genannt.
Gut 50 Prozent dieser Shadowfleet ist nicht in russischer Hand.
Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass sich damit de facto die Russland zur Verfügung
stehende Transportkapazität mal so eben umsetzen.
So insert your number hier, irgendwas zwischen 20 und 50 Prozent verringert
hat, beziehungsweise der Rest dann auch automatisch auch nochmal teurer wird.
Also sowohl die Kapazität sinkt, als auch die Kosten steigen,
während die Einnahmen aus dem eigentlichen Verkauf auch weiter sinken.
Also zuletzt waren wir jetzt bei 34, 32 oder 34 Dollar. das ändert sich jetzt
auch laufend, für Öl aus dem Schwarzen Meer.
Ein bisschen mehr gibt es für die Versorgung über die baltischen Häfen.
Wäre ja vielleicht mal auch zu überlegen, ob man nicht mal die russischen Tanker
einfach mal nicht zwischen Schweden und Dänemark durchlässt.
Wäre jetzt auch nochmal eine Maßnahme, aber da kommen wir vielleicht nochmal
drüber, wenn wir über die Politik reden.
Summa summarum, läuft alles nicht so gut. Russland hat auch Schwierigkeiten da entgegenzuhalten.
Unter anderem haben sie dann ja noch so einen Angriff gefakt.
Also sie haben dann so einen Tanker, der irgendwo in Novorossisk lag,
haben sie dann vor der türkischen Küste, haben sie auch gesagt,
oh ja, hier sind ja voll angegriffen worden von der Ukraine mit irgendwie Drohnen.
Aber man hat halt irgendwie gesehen aus anderen Beobachtungen,
dass das wahrscheinlich das Ergebnis eines Angriffs in Novorossisk war.
Und es macht auch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn für die Ukrainer halt ein Schiff,
was gerade von Novorossist kommt, anzugreifen, weil es ja dann potenziell eben beladen wäre.
Und es handelte sich dabei auch nicht um einen Öltanker, sondern um einen,
Weiß nicht, irgendwas anderes habe ich jetzt gerade vergessen.
Also macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn und so ein typisches Ablenkungsmanöver,
da sind die Russen ja dann immer sehr fix dabei, aber selten hält das in irgendeiner
näheren Betrachtung Stand.
Als das losging, wurde dann auch erstmal gemutmaßt, was denn jetzt die Russen
als Vergeltung machen würden.
Und da wurde dann vermutet, dass sie jetzt dafür halt die Getreideexporte der Ukraine,
die über das Schwarze Meer gehen, dass sie dort halt Getreideschiffe angreifen
könnten oder Sonnenblumenöl-Tanker.
Ich meine, gestern wurde zumindest von den Russen auch in Odessa einen Speicher
mit Sonnenblumenöl angegriffen.
Und ansonsten, ja, hatten sie irgendwie dann vor allem in Odessa,
so schwerpunktmäßig ein bisschen mehr angegriffen. sie nicht so,
dass sie vorher nicht auch in Odessa den Hafen und die Hafenanlagen und so beschossen haben.
Und haben aber dieses Mal dann auch ein türkisches Schiff getroffen.
Was keine gute Idee ist.
So, und das hat dann wiederum auch zu einer türkischen Reaktion geführt.
Und die Türken schießen seitdem jetzt alle Drohnen über dem Schwarzen Meer,
die da irgendwie in ihre Nähe kommen, werden jetzt aktuell von der Türkei einfach abgeschossen.
Die Türkei hat jetzt schon mindestens zwei russische Überwachungsdrohnen,
die der Türkei zu nahe gekommen sind, einfach abgeschossen.
Ja, also Erdogan hat ja schon mehrfach bewiesen, dass er sozusagen da vor den
Russen nicht zurückzuckt.
Also wenn alle in Europa sich mal so aufstellen würden wie Erdogan,
womit ich nicht sagen will, dass seine Politik gruppierungswürdig ist,
bevor ihr mich falsch versteht.
Aber was das Verhältnis gegenüber den Russen betrifft, da hat er auf jeden Fall
ein ganz anderes Rückgrat.
Wie man die Russen einhegt, da hat er in der Vergangenheit auch gezeigt, wie man das macht.
In der Tat.
Und die andere Sache ist, was es aber auch zeigt ist, dass Russland jetzt keine
großartigen Reserven hat,
um jetzt besonders heftig zuzuschlagen nach diesen Angriffen,
sondern sie fahren halt schon die ganze Zeit auf Verschleiß und 120 Prozent.
Und da können sie nicht einfach dann auf 130 hochgehen, wenn sowas passiert.
Weil ja, also das zeigt es zumindest auch diese Geschichte, weil das schon natürlich
eine krasse Eskalation jetzt auch nochmal von der Ukraine ist.
Ukraine hat Eskalationspotenzial. Und die Russen haben eigentlich nicht wirklich
mehr Eskalationspotenzial.
Also da ist schon alles maximal schlimm.
Und ja, Ukraine hat auf jeden Fall noch einiges im Köcher.
Ja, kommen wir noch auf ein paar andere erwähnenswerte Maßnahmen in dem Zusammenhang.
Also Drohnenkampagne ist auch sehr erfolgreich von der Ukraine.
Speziell auf der Krim, nicht nur auf der Krim, aber vor allem auf der Krim.
Dort ist es ihnen gerade jetzt in den letzten Tagen und Wochen gelungen,
mehrere Militärflugzeuge abzuschießen, MiG-31,
Su-24, Su-27 teilweise auf der Startbahn mit ihren FP-1-Drohnen.
Wir sehen den Taganrock, das ist auch noch auf russischem, also offiziell russischem
Gebiet am Asowschen Meer.
Da ist so eine wichtige Repair Facility, die hatten sie auch schon mal angegriffen.
Dort haben sie, glaube ich, auch noch so das letzte dieser AVAX-Flugzeuge,
die die Russen noch hatten, diese A-20 offensichtlich erwischt.
Und es kamen jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen nochmal weitere Zahlen rein.
Man findet schon wieder fast den Überblick.
Also es ist ihnen jetzt in den letzten Tagen gelungen, wirklich richtig viele
Militärflugzeuge der Russen zu erwischen.
Muss man dazu sagen, die haben auch noch ganz viele. Also es ist sozusagen nicht
so, dass denen jetzt schon die Flugzeuge ausgehen. Aber das ist alles sehr, sehr, sehr teuer.
Und vor allem sind diese Flugzeuge nicht mal so eben zu ersetzen.
Teilweise handelt es sich auch um Modelle, die schon gar nicht mehr gebaut werden.
Und dann dementsprechend auch komplett weg sind.
Oder die von der Ukraine gebaut wurden.
Genau, oder sowas. Teilweise fallen die Flugzeuge jetzt auch schon von alleine runter.
Da gibt es ein schönes Video von so einem Transportflugzeug,
einem alten, das war glaube ich so ein altes ukrainisches, was einfach in der
Mitte durchgebrochen ist und dann runtergefallen ist.
Also das war definitiv auch so beyond Wartungszyklus, was natürlich auch zeigt,
dass die Russen in zunehmendem Maße auch Probleme haben, Wartung durchzuführen
und überhaupt noch Ersatzteile ranzubekommen.
Ähnliche Auswirkungen gibt es auch im zivilen Luftverkehr.
Also das ist definitiv ein Bereich, wo sie gerade nicht besonders gut dastehen.
Und generell ist diese russische Militärtechnik auch einfach gefährlicher,
was man dann wiederum gesehen hat, jetzt bei den zwei Piloten,
wo der Schleudersitz ausgelöst wurde, während sie im Hangar waren und die getötet hat.
Und ja, es ist wohl bei dem Flugzeug so eine bekannte Schwäche,
dass das passieren kann, dass man beim Ein- oder Aussteigen,
wenn man da nicht aufpasst,
so kann man wohl versehentlich den Schleudersitz auslösen.
Das ist, habe ich gehört, es ist so ein bekanntes Risiko eigentlich,
weswegen die Piloten dann speziell trailliert werden, genau das nicht zu machen, weil, ja.
Weiß man nicht, was der Grund war, also ob das vielleicht auch eine Fehlfunktion war?
Ja, man weiß es nicht, wird es wahrscheinlich auch nie wissen,
weil es auch immer an Untersuchungen da rauskommt.
Aber was ich gehört habe von so Leuten, die sich mit dem Flugzeug auskennen,
ja, da gibt es halt irgendwie dieser Hebel, der hängt da so ein bisschen in der Gegend,
wo man echt aufpassen muss.
Und ja...
Sieht auf jeden Fall gerade nicht besonders gut aus für die Russen auf der Krim.
Und auch mit, es gab da noch so ein U-Boot, was irgendwie im Mittelmeer,
wo in der Nähe von Gibraltar dann halb gestrandet ist.
Die mussten irgendwie auftauchen, hatten irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
ob die einen Brand hatten oder was das Problem war.
Auf jeden Fall musste das dann wieder langsam nach Hause tuckern.
Keine Ahnung, ob es mittlerweile schon angekommen ist. Es musste quasi einmal
um Europa rum und nach Sankt Petersburg kommen.
Also ihnen fällt auch so ein bisschen alles auseinander, hat man so fast den Eindruck.
Außerdem behauptet die Ukraine, also man hat auch gesehen in den letzten Monaten
eine Unmenge an Videos über zerstörte Radarsysteme, Flugabwehrsysteme.
Angeblich ist die Hälfte des Bestands der Panzerflugabwehrsysteme der Russen
mittlerweile vernichtet worden in diesem Krieg, wenn man den Aufzeichnungen glauben darf.
Also insgesamt erhöht sich einfach der Druck durch ukrainische Drohnenangriffe
extrem und es macht auch den Eindruck,
dass speziell in der Krim mittlerweile die Radarabdeckung so geschwächt ist,
dass einfach immer mehr Angriffe möglich ist.
Also die letzten Flugzeuge, die zerstört wurden, die wurden halt direkt auf der Airbase zerstört.
Als sie noch auf der Startbahn waren, mit Waffen drunter.
Und auf den Videos sah man sogar noch Crew, die da gerade irgendwas montiert
hat. Oder vielleicht waren es auch die Piloten, weiß man natürlich nicht.
Also da ist es so mit der Absicherung so eine Sache.
Und die letzten zwei Flugzeuge, die zerstört wurden, wurden ja per Sabotage zerstört.
Das war dann aber woanders, nicht in der Krim, sondern irgendwo tiefer in Russland drin.
Das heißt, dort hat sich dann ein Spezialteam der Ukraine, Die haben irgendwie,
also das ist jetzt die Eigendarstellung der Ukrainer, die hätten also angeblich
zwei Wochen dort den Betrieb beobachtet.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die mit so vielen Details nach draußen gehen,
aber die werden schon ihre Gründe haben.
Und haben dann die Zeitpläne der Bewachung, du hast es anfangs schon erwähnt,
dass ihnen ja so ein bisschen das Personal auch ausgeht auf diesen ganzen Standorten.
Das heißt, da kommt dann nur ab und zu mal einer vorbei und guckt,
dass noch alles irgendwie in Ordnung ist.
Und das haben sie dann halt einfach durch Beobachtung rausgefunden,
haben sich in die Hangar geschlichen, haben die Dinger einfach unter Feuer gesetzt,
haben das schön gefilmt und wieder davon gezogen und wieder zwei Flugzeuge weniger.
Sie waren sogar tatsächlich im Cockpit drin.
Sie haben sozusagen direkt auch Brandsätze dann im Cockpit und an kritischen Stellen deponiert.
Es scheint so, dass sie auch wussten, wo man die Brandsätze am besten hinpackt,
dass da nichts Verwertbares mehr übrig bleibt.
Und ja, insgesamt sind fast zehn Flugzeuge in einer Woche oder so,
die sie insgesamt verloren haben.
Und das ist schon für jede Luftwaffe. Weil die Amerikaner meinten,
also wenn die jetzt in einer Woche zehn Flugzeuge verlieren würden,
das wäre halt eine unvorstellbare Dimension.
Also selbst im Golfkrieg oder so, wenn das passiert wäre, dann...
Ja, also Katastrophe.
Und auch wenn sie jetzt noch genug haben, oder was heißt genug?
Ich weiß nicht, die aktuellen Zahlen sind nicht alle auswendig,
aber ich glaube so von diesen wichtigen SU 27 oder 24 oder 34,
keine Ahnung, ich habe den Überblick verloren.
Also auf jeden Fall, die haben so im dreistelligen Bereich welche gehabt, so 200, 300,
so gut 100 davon, sind irgendwie jetzt auch schon vernichtet worden und wenn
das so weitergeht, dann ist dann irgendwann auch nicht mehr von einer Übermacht zu sprechen.
Zumal ja wiederum sich das Arsenal der Ukrainer eher steigert.
Also Berichte von abgeschossenen F-16 habe ich jetzt keine mitbekommen.
Es gab halt Unfälle, es gab also einen F-16, die im Einsatz abgeschossen wurde.
Es gab eine Mirage, die glaube ich von alleine abgestürzt ist,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so endemisch, dass das jetzt irgendwie im laufenden Meter passieren würde.
Dazu kommt, dass auch die F-16-Face.
In zunehmendem Maße auch aufgerüstet werden. Also obwohl es ältere F-16 sind,
kriegen sie teilweise aktualisiertes Material.
Wir haben jetzt so diese neuen, habe ich den Namen vergessen,
aber so Leitsysteme für dumme Raketen, mit denen sie also Drohnen noch zuverlässiger abschießen können.
Moderne Technik, die nachgerüstet wird. Also es verbessert sich an der Stelle.
Sprich, die Balance im Luftkrieg ändert sich. Aber dort hat Russland definitiv
immer noch eine Überlegenheit.
Obendrauf zu den Unfällen und zu den Angriffen gibt es dann auch noch Attentate.
Es gab jetzt gerade vorgestern, gestern, vorgestern gab es ein weiteres erfolgreiches
Attentat auf einen russischen General. Das ist dann schon der dritte innerhalb eines Jahres in Moskau.
Also dort haben sie ihn mit seinem eigenen Auto oder mit einem Auto,
in das er gestiegen ist, hops genommen. sprich Sprengsatz gezündet.
Und das ist also sozusagen auch noch ein zusätzliches Gefahrenpotenzial,
mit dem die russische Militär-Elite rechnen muss, dass die Ukrainerinnen dann
auch noch auf ihrem Home-Turf auflauern.
Ja, damit aber nicht genug. Es gibt weitere Nachrichten in dieser Hinsicht und
was der absolute Hammer der letzten Zeit war,
war natürlich die Zerstörung eines Kilo-Class-U-Boots im Militärhafen von Novorossisk.
Die Russen hatten ja jetzt über lange, lange Zeit, auch als die Krim noch zur
Ukraine gehörte, den Militärhafen in Sevastopol auf der Krim und den halten
sie natürlich auch immer noch.
Aber die russische Marine, wir haben ja mehrfach darüber berichtet,
des Schwarzen Meeres, die Schwarze Meerflotte hat sich weitgehend aus diesem
Hafen zurückgezogen, weil einfach nicht mehr zu verteidigen war.
Die Ukraine hat dort ein U-Boot mit einer Neptun-Rakete versenkt,
als es gerade im Trockendock lag.
Sie haben zahlreiche andere Schiffe dort angegriffen, zerstört teilweise, versenkt.
Sie haben mit ihren Marine-Drohnen nahezu alle anderen Schiffe aus dem Schwarzen
Meer verdrängt und ein Großteil dieser Schiffe liegt jetzt im Militärhafen in
Novorossisk und traut sich kaum raus.
Unter anderem waren dort auch drei U-Boote stationiert, vielleicht waren es
auch mehr, aber mindestens drei.
Verschiedener Arten und die problematischste der U-Boot-Typen sind eben diese Kilo.
Also so heißt diese Kilo-Class, diese Art von U-Booten. Warum?
Weil diese halt auch Launcher sind für diese Kinza-Raketen, mit denen die Ukraine angegriffen wird.
Und eben genau eins dieser U-Boote, von denen mutmaßlich auch Raketen auf die
Ukraine abgeschossen wurden, wurde jetzt Opfer eines Angriffs und zwar von einer Unterwasserdrohne.
Mit anderen Worten, die Ukraine hat jetzt wieder einen neuen Typ von Drohne
gebaut, also quasi so ein selbstfahrender Torpedo oder sich selbst lenkender Torpedo.
Es ist nichts darüber bekannt, wie das Ding genau funktioniert.
Es ist nichts darüber bekannt, von wo es aus gestartet ist, ob das jetzt wirklich
das gesamte Schwarze Meer durchschwommen hat oder ob sie das in irgendeiner
Form mit dem Flugzeug irgendwo abgeworfen haben. We don't know.
Nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Was wir aber sehr genau wissen ist,
was passiert ist, als diese Drohne am Hafen angekommen ist.
Nämlich in diesem Militärhafen, also das ist sozusagen in dem Hafen oder in
dieser Bucht von Novorossisk, hat der Militärhafen nochmal so einen eigenen
Bereich und der ist auch nochmal mit so einer eigenen Mauer eingezäunt.
Am Eingang sind vielleicht Netze installiert gewesen, man weiß es nicht.
Auf jeden Fall ist diese Drohne dort rein und ist dann zielstrebig auf eins
dieser dort liegenden U-Boote zu und ist in allernächster Nähe unter Wasser
explodiert mit einem ziemlichen Wumms. Warum wissen wir das so genau?
Weil die Ukrainer auch noch ein Video veröffentlicht haben von einer Überwachungskamera
der Russen in diesem Hafen und so wie es aussieht, haben die nicht nur die Footage bekommen,
sondern das sah für mich eher so aus, als ob sie diese Kamera bewusst gesteuert haben,
weil sie sozusagen schön so nach links geschwenkt sind.
Ja, guck mal, hier ist der Militärhafen und da macht es gleich Bums und dann macht es Bums.
Und es gab diese riesige Unterwasserexplosion.
Später auf Satellitenbildern hat man dann gesehen, wie heftig die Explosion
war, weil das dann sozusagen genau in dieser Ecke der Einfassungsmauer dieses
Militärhafens stattfand.
Und von dieser Ecke ist irgendwie gefühlt 30, 40 Prozent weg explodiert worden.
Also der Wumms war enorm.
Was ein bisschen schwierig auszumachen war, inwiefern das U-Boot jetzt Schaden genommen hat.
Aber dass es Schaden genommen hat, das ist relativ wahrscheinlich aus zwei Gründen.
Erstens, in zwei, drei Metern Entfernung eine Explosion dieser Dimension,
die enorm war, weil das sieht man an den Schäden an der Mauer, unter Wasser.
Wird sozusagen dieser Druck ja sofort weitergegeben, weil sich Wasser nicht komprimieren lässt.
Luft lässt sich komprimieren und wenn so eine Explosion in der Luft stattfindet,
dann geht immer ein Großteil der Explosion quasi in die Luft.
Und du hast zwar den Schaden durch die Druckwelle und durch Splitter und so
weiter, aber du hast nicht den vollen Impact.
Unter Wasser sieht das ganz anders aus. Deswegen reicht es in der Regel aus,
Bomben in der Nähe von Schiffen oder vor allem von U-Booten zu zünden,
um denen doch erheblichen Schaden zuzuführen.
Jetzt war das aber, sagen wir mal, an dem U-Boot selber nicht zu sehen und es
war so ein bisschen Spekulation, ob das jetzt so ein bisschen tiefer im Wasser sitzt oder so.
Aber was man gesehen hat, ist, es lag da noch und alle anderen U-Boote,
die da waren, die waren alle weg.
Das heißt, sie haben alles weggefahren, nur das Teil haben sie nicht weggefahren,
vermutlich, weil sie es nicht mehr wegfahren konnten.
Und deswegen gehen alle davon aus, dass das Ding im Eimer ist.
Also weil man vermutet, dass es sich um die B271 Colpino handelt.
Und das ist deswegen auch nochmal interessant, weil es halt eine Improved Kilo-Class ist.
Also diese elektrische Wote, die schon seit Jahrzehnten im Einsatz sind wahrscheinlich.
Aber das ist sozusagen die moderne Kilo-Klasse.
Also das Ding ist nicht uralt.
Also ein Hybrid mit zusätzlichem Elektromotor.
Ja, das hatten die vorher auch. Aber das ist halt eine modernisiert,
also eine verbesserte Variante.
Nennt sich Improved Kilo Class,
die Bezeichnung. Und ja, also nach dem, was ich gesehen habe,
auch an den Satellitenbildern und was eben auch interessant war,
dass halt du auf den Satellitenbildern natürlich nur siehst,
was den Teil von dem U-Boot, der sich über Wasser befindet. Und.
Und wenn man dann guckt, wie viel da noch unter Wasser,
also wie weit das dann noch unter Wasser geht, wo dann die Schraube hinten auch
dran ist, das ist alles natürlich unter Wasser und das war dann quasi mitten auch in der Ecke.
Also ich würde mal stark vermuten.
Dass das Ding
massiv geschädigt ist und dass das Ding in eine Werft muss und zerlegt werden
muss und quasi da ein neues Heck und neue Schraube und neue Welle und so kriegen muss.
Da bin ich mir, würde ich sagen, 90, 95 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit nach all dem.
Nur haben sie dort diese Werftkapazitäten nicht.
Also es gibt welche in Sevastopol. Das heißt,
sie könnten irgendwie das Ding nach Sevastopol schleppen oder dann eben nächster
Platz zum Reparieren wäre dann irgendwie einmal rum um Europa.
Das heißt, die Vermutung ist jetzt, mangels Werftkapazität bleibt das Ding da
jetzt liegen für nicht absehbare Zeit und wird möglicherweise gar nicht repariert werden können.
Aber wir werden sehen. so also im Moment sieht aber jedenfalls nicht gut aus
und definitiv auch peinlich für die Russen, die natürlich behauptet nichts passiert, alles in Ordnung,
keine Schäden so.
Ja ja also das war auf jeden Fall das war jetzt für die Russen natürlich ein
Schock auf mehreren Ebenen, also erstens,
Ein U-Boot. Ich meine, das ist von all ihren Fahrzeugen eigentlich das,
was man am besten verstecken kann.
Und wo eigentlich die Ukrainer die wenigsten Möglichkeiten hatten,
dem überhaupt in irgendeiner Form beizukommen. Würde man meinen.
Stellt sich raus, ist anders jetzt.
Dann die Sache mit der Videokamera. Ist halt auch wirklich crazy.
Also wenn sozusagen im eigenen Militärhafen die Videokameras von den Ukrainern
gehijackt werden, wo schauen sie sonst noch zu?
Also sind sie jetzt auch an den ganzen Flugplätzen schon in den Überwachungskameras
mit drin und können genau sehen, wann da das Personal wechselt?
Also vielleicht ist das ja der Grund, dass die anderen Flugzeuge da in Flammen aufgegangen sind.
Also das ist definitiv überhaupt gar keine gute Meldung für die psychologische
Kriegsführung dort und ja, muss man mal schauen, was da noch kommt.
Ja, ich meine, was die Russen als Reaktion jetzt daraufhin gemacht haben, ist,
dass sie die Einfahrt nochmal jetzt mit Schiffen im Prinzip blockiert haben,
sodass die Vermutung naheliegt, dass diese Subsea Babys über Torpedonetze rüberspringen können.
Ja, das heißt, die kommen halt unter Wasser angefahren, sehen halt ein Torpedonetz.
Was heißt Vermutung? Also das war so eine Theorie, dass man sowas ja vielleicht
mal ausprobieren könnte, aber dass das stattgefunden hat, davon gibt es jetzt
keinerlei Erkenntnisse.
Ja, gut, aber es ist, es macht halt Sinn, vor dem Hintergrund,
dass die Russen da jetzt den Eingang mit den Barges dann,
Sebastian Batschoffe Schwimmleichter.
Shooter heißt das.
Ja, mit Shootern. Ja, dass sie das blockiert haben,
weil offensichtlich die Torpedonetze nicht ausreichen.
Das war so ein bisschen die These, ob das Ding vielleicht über das Netz rübergesprungen
ist und dann wäre halt jetzt noch diese Shoot dahinter.
Ja, okay, gut. Also wissen wir nicht genau. Das hat jetzt das Video nicht gezeigt.
Genauso könnte man natürlich ein Netz auch einfach durch eine Vorab-Explosion
erstmal auflösen und dann mit dem eigentlichen Torpedo hinterherkommen.
Und das ist dann, glaube ich, eh so ein bisschen die Gefahr.
Also das war jetzt ein Torpedo, von dem man gesehen hat oder von so einem,
wie sagt man jetzt, Underwater,
UUD, also die Abkürzung, UAV,
ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wofür es steht, aber es gibt jetzt auf jeden
Fall wieder eine neue Abkürzung.
Mein Gott, man das überfordert hier mit diesem ganzen technologischen Fortschritt.
Auf jeden Fall, das hat stattgefunden und das ist ein weiteres Thema,
worüber sich die russische Militärsicherheit Gedanken machen muss,
wie sie darauf antworten werden.
Kommen wir vielleicht nochmal so zu der eigentlichen Produktion der Ukraine.
Also die Waffenproduktion der Ukraine steigt ja laufend an und nach eigener
Auskunft produziert die Ukraine jetzt circa oder bis zu 800 Drohnen pro Tag.
Das sagt jetzt nicht aus welcher Art Drohnen in welchen Mengen,
das ist sozusagen nur das, was so genannt wird und es gibt dokumentierte Tage,
wo die bis zu 700 Drohnen in Richtung Russland geschickt haben.
Keine Aussage darüber, wie viel darunter wirklich eine Wirkung entfaltet haben,
aber man sieht das dann wiederum bei den russischen Bloggern,
die das dann entsprechend dokumentieren, genauso wie die Ukraine das dokumentiert,
wenn die Russen anfliegen.
Wobei wir nur von jetzt größeren Langstreckendrohnen reden, nicht jetzt von FPV-Drohnen.
Ja genau, größere Systeme, die jetzt wirklich in der Lage sind Russland anzugreifen
und nicht an der Front, sondern eben jenseits der Grenze.
Also von denen produzieren sie glaube ich Tausende am Tag.
Ja und sie meinen auch ganz lässig, sie hätten mehr von diesen FPV Drones als
die russischen Soldaten haben.
Also für jeden ist einer da und macht euch mal keine Hoffnung.
Genau, dann haben wir schon über diese Interceptor-Drones gesprochen,
die sind halt nach wie vor auch stark in der Produktion, da gibt es jetzt keine
konkreten Zahlen, die halt einfach irgendwo stehen, vertikal aufsteigen können,
sehr schnell unterwegs sind, paar hundert Stundenkilometer erreichen und in
der Lage sind, so Schahets einzufangen.
Aber nicht nur das, die auch in der Lage sind, dass wenn sie der Auffassung
sind, dass sie ihr Ziel nicht erreichen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
also Fehlalarm oder Drohne schon zu weit weg oder was weiß ich,
dass sie auch wieder landen können.
Das heißt, sie sind dann nicht verloren, sondern das ist quasi Munition,
die wieder zurückkommt und auch ein zweites Mal zum Einsatz kommen kann,
die dann vielleicht nochmal nachgeladen werden müssen, aber die zumindest nicht verloren sind.
Sprich, so eine Interceptor-Drohne ist potenziell eine Munition,
die zu 100% zum Einsatz auch wirklich kommt.
Also nicht vielleicht immer zu 100% Erfolg hat, aber zumindest jetzt nicht wie
jetzt Artillerie-Munition, die einfach irgendwo landet, wo sie nicht gebraucht
wird, sondern im Wesentlichen ja einfach vergeudet ist.
Sehr effizient und wenn ich das richtig sehe, auch so ein bisschen der Erfolgsgarant
der letzten Wochen sind diese FP1-Drohnen.
Jetzt habe ich es vergessen. FP ist die Abkürzung Firepoint.
Genau, Firepoint dieser Produktionsfirma,
also einer dieser privaten Waffenproduktionsfirmen in der Ukraine.
Die sind wohl sehr effizient. Also die kommen weit und die sind vor allem dafür
verantwortlich, dass die ganzen Ölraffinerien in Flammen aufgehen.
Dann haben sie neue Versionen von dieser Neptun-Rakete vorgestellt.
Also diese Cruise Missile, mit der sie die Moskva, das Flaggschiff der Schwarzmeerflotte
der Russen, versenkt haben einst.
Davon gibt es halt so eine Long-Range-Version, die wohl ganz erfolgreich zu
sein scheint und für einige Angriffe verantwortlich ist.
Es ist immer noch so ein bisschen ein Rätsel mit diesen Flamingo-Drohnen,
weil sie ja meinten, sie würden davon jetzt irgendwie sieben pro Tag erzeugen.
Es gibt Aussagen darüber, dass die wohl auch schon zum Einsatz gekommen seien,
aber es gibt so ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass die eine sehr hohe Abschlussrate noch haben.
Dass die also so wie sie derzeit funktionieren und die basieren ja quasi auf
so einem alten Raketentriebwerk, von dem die Ukraine noch eine Menge rumliegen hatte.
Aber das reicht wohl noch nicht. Die sind einfach zu groß und zu langsam und
können von der russischen Flugabwehr zu leicht erkannt und dann entsprechend abgeschossen werden.
Ich habe irgendwas gehört, dass die dann nur zusammen mit Neptun zum Einsatz
kommen, wobei mir nicht so ganz klar ist, was da der Vorteil sein soll.
Und es gibt so ein bisschen die Aussage, dass die so richtig erst ihre Kraft
entfalten können, wenn es ihnen gelingt, in 30 Meter Höhe zu fliegen,
also sprich unter dem Radar.
Und das war so eine Aussage, die so ein bisschen klang wie, wir arbeiten mit
unseren Partnern zusammen, um hochauflösende Satellitendaten zu bekommen,
damit wir solche Modelle machen können.
Es ist so ein bisschen wie mit diesen Taurus Cruise Missiles der Bundeswehr,
die ja dafür bekannt sind, genau das zu tun.
Weil sie eben mit einem hochauflösenden Relief-Modell der Welt gebaut sind und
wenn man sie dann halt auf einen konkreten Einsatz schickt,
dann lädt man eben genau dieses Terrain in die Cruise Missile rein,
ins Taurus und dann kann sie sozusagen selber erkennen und ist unabhängig von
irgendeiner Funkkommunikation und kann mit Electronic Warfare nicht so ohne
weiteres zumindest ausgeschaltet werden, sondern ich weiß selber so, ah okay,
ich fliege hier rüber, ich erkenne das Terrain und matche das auf meine Datenbank.
Im Prinzip ist das so Real-Time-KI auf einem Geländemodell, sprich diese Missiles
fliegen, scannen selbstständig, wahrscheinlich mit Laser.
Ihre Umgebung und haben dann eben über so einen ML-Machine-Learning-Algorithmus
oder auch KI-Algorithmus, wie man es nennen möchte, sehr schnell einen Match
auf A, ich fliege gerade hier lang, also muss ich jetzt da weiter.
Und ich weiß, da hinten kommt ein Haus, da muss ich dann vorbei,
hier ist ein Berg, da muss ich höher fliegen.
Aber ich fliege halt selten mehr als 30 Meter über dem Grund und bin aber in
der Lage, Obstacles zu vermeiden.
Und offenbar, so lese ich das jetzt ein bisschen raus aus diesen Statements,
sind sie dabei, diesen Flamingos und potenziell natürlich auch ihren Neptuns,
diese Fähigkeit überzuhelfen.
Und wenn das dann soweit ist, dann können die erst ihre Kraft entfalten.
Das muss man dann sehen.
Ja, es gibt da bei diesem, ich sag mal, bei Terrain-Following gibt es verschiedene Verfahren,
so Terrain-Contour-Matching ist eins davon und wodurch die sich unterscheiden,
ist die Art der Sensoren, die du brauchst.
Die einfachste Variante ist, du hast einfach einen Radar-Altimeter,
das nach unten guckt, so direkt unter dich und dann hast du im Grunde genommen
nur die Höheninformation unter dir und versuchst es dann daraus zu machen.
Dann erweiterten Systeme haben dann halt mehrere Radar-Entfernungsmesser,
die dann auch nach vorne gucken und ein bisschen nach rechts und nach links.
Und dann gibt es eben auch Systeme, die dann einfach das mit Kameras machen
oder eine Kombination aus Kamera und Radar.
Und je nachdem, je mehr Sensorik und Intelligenz du da jetzt drin hast,
umso teurer wird das Ganze natürlich auch.
Deswegen gibt es einen Grund, warum so eine Taurus halt eine Million kostet,
weil die halt so ziemlich alles hat, was man...
Was man gerne hätte, bis hin dann zu, ja, im Endanflug ein Bild von dem Gebäude
oder so und dann das ganze Fenster markieren, wo die reingehen soll.
Ich nehme mal nicht an, dass diese Flamingo jetzt so viele Sensoren hat,
sondern das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sparsamer ausgestattet.
Und das könnte halt auch noch so ein bisschen das Problem sein.
Plus, so wie sie aussieht, könnte sie halt einen sehr hohen Radarquerschnitt
haben, verglichen jetzt mit den FP1 oder 2,
die es ja schaffen,
permanent auch direkt in Luftabwehrstellungen reinzufliegen zu fliegen und das
Radar zu zerstören, wo man ja meinen würde,
dass gerade solche Luftabwehrstellungen in der Lage sein müssten, sich zu verteidigen.
Aber so, was ich gesehen habe, ja.
Fliegen die da mehr oder weniger ungestört rein, noch nicht mal mit besonders hoher Geschwindigkeit,
und so, sondern zerstören sondern einfach dort die Flugabwehrsysteme,
entweder weil vielleicht die gerade nicht an sind oder ich weiß es nicht,
was da der Grund ist, warum mit diesen relativ langsam fliegenden Superbilden,
die kosten auch, ich glaube, 50.000 Dollar gerade mal,
und damit ein Drittel von dem, was eine Scheid-Drohne kostet.
Das ist also auch nochmal sehr seltsam.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall...
Die Situation in der ganzen Produktion und bei der Waffentechnik,
also generell entwickelt sich natürlich dieser ganze Drohnenbereich extrem.
Einerseits was die Technologie betrifft, andererseits auch was die ganzen Einsatzstrategien betrifft.
Und was man ja jetzt zum Beispiel in letzter Zeit immer wieder gesehen hat,
auch zum Beispiel als der Selenski vor Krupiansk da sein Video aufgenommen hat.
Der war ja dann sozusagen in Spunkweite des Kampfgeschehens und während er dann
auch das Video aufgenommen hat, hörtest du im Hintergrund so Explosionen und so.
Er stand aber neben dieser Hauptstraße, die in die Stadt reinführt und die Straße
war halt so komplett in so Netze eingehüllt. Das ist jetzt einfach der Standard.
Auch Herson und viele andere Frontstädte haben ihre Versorgungsstraßen komplett
mit so Drohnen, so Antidrohnennetzen versorgt.
Das heißt, man hat links und rechts so Masten aufgespannt und drumherum quasi
Netze, damit eben so eine Drohne sich da drin verfängt oder eben nur dort explodieren
kann und dann potenziell keinen Schaden ausrichtet.
Da das jetzt so überall zu sehen ist, nehme ich mal an, wird es auch einen gewissen Erfolg haben.
Aber jetzt gibt es dann halt wiederum von den Russen und ich vermute auch von
den Ukrainern, und die Russen haben das, ich habe es von den Russen jetzt gehört,
aber ich vermute mal, die Ukrainer machen das auch, weil die ja schon damit experimentiert haben.
Die verwenden dann wiederum Termit-Drohnen. Das hatten wir schon mal als Angriff
auf Schützengräben. Hat sich irgendwie nicht so richtig durchgesetzt, weiß nicht warum.
Auf jeden Fall Termit, also dieses...
Extrem heiße Zeug, was man normalerweise zum Schweißen von Eisenbahnschienen verwendet.
Wir fliegen sie dann über diese Netze, um diese Netze abzubrennen,
um dann sozusagen den Weg wieder frei zu machen.
Es ist ein permanentes Hin und Her in der ganzen Waffentechnik auf allen Fronten.
Hast du eigentlich diese Glasfaser-Drohnen-Abwehr- Technologie?
Du meinst mit dem NATO-Draht, ne?
Genau, das haben wir schon erwähnt.
Wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, diese Methode, einfach Nato-Draht zu spannen,
links und rechts einen Motor, dann drehen die sich die ganze Zeit und wenn jetzt
eine Glasfaser-Drohne rüberfliegt und die Glasfaser auf dem Boden sinkt,
also auf diesen Draht sinkt, dann wird der halt automatisch,
zermarmelt. Das sind alles solche,
kreativen Lösungen.
Ja, mittlerweile auch krass, dass so in manchen Gegenden wie die mit Glasfasern
überzogen sind, wie so ein gigantisches Spinnennetz im Grunde genommen.
Und wo auch dann Robert J. Bro meinte,
dass in tausenden von Jahren wahrscheinlich Archäologen, wenn die dann den Boden dort untersuchen,
so eine Schicht finden werden, wo dann besonders viele Glasfaserpartikel drin sein werden.
Ja, das wird auch nochmal eine große Frage werden, wie sich das auf das Ökosystem auswirkt.
Also diese Menge an Glasfaser, die wird sicherlich zu großen Teilen dann in
der Erde verbleiben und das kann auch nicht gut sein für die Menschen.
Für die Fauna und vielleicht auch nicht für die Flora.
Okay, wie auch immer, ich würde sagen, wir gehen jetzt mal von den ganzen militärischen
Aspekten auf die politischen Aspekte. Da ist ja auch einiges passiert.
Wir haben auch über einiges nicht berichtet. Das wollen wir auch nochmal nachholen.
Allen voran ein Blick auf die Innenpolitik in der Ukraine.
Darüber reden wir eigentlich relativ wenig. Man kann auch sagen,
gut so, weil, also nicht, dass wir darüber wenig reden, sondern es ist jetzt
auch, sagen wir mal, nicht viel Dramatisches passiert.
Worüber wir allerdings gesprochen hatten, waren die politischen Auseinandersetzen
und die ersten Unruhen und Demonstrationen, die im Land stattgefunden haben,
weil es ja die Versuche gab, kurzfristig durch eine Gesetzesänderung,
die Unabhängigkeit dieser Korruptionsbehörden,
die ja seit den Maidan-Revolutionen existieren und eben auch unabhängig gehalten werden sollten.
Die eben mehr unter eine präsidiale Kontrolle zu bekommen,
so ein bisschen mit diesem Argument, man befürchtet irgendwie russische Unterwanderung,
was ich nicht beurteilen kann, ob es da Fälle gegeben hat oder ob das in irgendeiner
Form ein valides Argument ist, auf jeden Fall war der Widerstand dagegen groß,
das wurde ja dann auch alles zurückgenommen.
Und siehe da, eben diese Korruptionsbehörden haben jetzt vor mittlerweile zwei
Monaten einen relativ großen Korruptionsskandal in der Ukraine aufgedeckt.
Und es handelte sich dabei um keine geringere Person als ein sehr enger Vertrauter von Zelensky,
den er sozusagen noch damals aus seinem Medienbusiness kannte und der Energieminister
geworden ist in der Ukraine.
Das heißt, der ist zuständig für den ganzen Betrieb der Kraftwerke und so weiter,
die ganze Energieinfrastruktur.
Ja und hier wurde eben bekannt, dass er und diverse Mitstreiter wohl im großen
Stil Korruption begangen haben.
Insofern, als dass eben Gelder, die zum Aufbau der Energieinfrastruktur verwendet
werden sollten, so verteilt und umgeleitet wurden, dass eben dort persönlich
Gewinne abgezogen wurden.
Er ist dann auch, dieser Typ ist dann ins Ausland geflohen.
Meines Wissens hat man ihn bisher auch noch nicht gefangen, aber das Ganze war
natürlich dann eine Riesen-News.
Ja, vor allem sehr problematisch für Selenskyj, der sich natürlich mit einigen
Vertrauten umgeben hat.
Ich meine, das kann man ja auch verstehen, wenn er da sozusagen mit so einem
Programm, wir machen jetzt alles anders,
dann bedienst du dich nicht primär aus der etablierten Politschicht,
sondern schaust halt erstmal, wem vertraue ich denn so persönlich eigentlich,
damit ich mir so halbwegs sicher sein kann, dass das jetzt hier alles in meine Richtung läuft.
Stellt sich raus, auch die besten Freunde können einen betrügen.
Inwiefern Selenskyj davon wusste, ist everyone's guess.
Ich kann nur sagen, es gibt keine konkreten Vorwürfe, dass er von irgendetwas wusste.
Und in der Folge wurde dann aber auch die komplette Führung,
die ganze Vorstandsriege dieses Energieministeriums ausgetauscht.
Weil man ja wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht wusste, wer wusste jetzt hier überhaupt
irgendwas und so weiter.
Also wurde da quasi einmal ratzeputzt alles rausgeworfen und neu besetzt.
Ja, war natürlich eine große Aufregung. Russland hat das natürlich auch sofort
genutzt und hier gesagt, guck mal hier, wie korrupt die sind,
haben wir ja schon immer gesagt.
Nur in Russland wäre das bestimmt nicht rausgekommen. Das ist sozusagen der Punkt.
Also laut den Berichten, die
man jetzt vor allem von ukrainischen Berichterstattern so entnehmen kann,
also Leute, die auch so populäre YouTube-Kanäle haben und so weiter,
in Interviews sagen die halt, naja,
das war nicht gut, aber im Wesentlichen ist man eigentlich froh,
dass es rausgekommen ist. Und das wird eher positiv gesehen.
Also man sieht, dass sozusagen eine Antikorruptionsbehörde in der Lage ist,
tatsächlich Korruption aufzudecken und dass das Konsequenzen hat.
Und das trägt schon dazu bei, auch weiterhin zur Regierung Selenskyj zu stehen.
Du wirst immer Gegner haben, aber die große Mehrheit ist halt nach wie vor hinter
der ukrainischen Regierung und ist auch sicherlich nicht davon überzeugt,
dass man jetzt mit einer russischen Führung besser gefahren wäre.
Ja, wohl kaum mehr.
Also ja, im Übrigen, ja, mal geguckt, ist alles so ein bisschen noch unklar,
aber sozusagen der Energieminister,
Germán Galuschenko oder Hermann Haluschenko,
der war auf jeden Fall verwickelt, da gab es irgendwie,
Aufnahmen auch, er wurde halt
abgehört und bestreitet allerdings wohl
alles wer der engste Vertraute von oder der enge Vertraute von Selensky war
eher Timur Mindic der damals irgendwie Mitbesitzer von Quartal 95 Entertainment war,
wo Selensky vorher quasi gearbeitet hat, also seine Filmkarriere gemacht hat.
Und der ist derjenige, der jetzt geflohen ist wohl nach Polen, wie es aussieht.
Aber niemand ist bisher verurteilt in dem Sinne. und der Energieminister bestreitet
irgendwie jegliche Schuld. Aber ja.
Wie heißt er nochmal? Timor...
Timur Mindig.
Genau. Das war ja so ein bisschen die rechte Hand auch von Selenskyj. Also in der Regierung.
Es gibt da kaum Aufnahmen von irgendwelchen wichtigen Ereignissen,
wo der nicht mit im Bild ist.
Und das hatte ich jetzt ein bisschen zusammengeworfen, die beiden Personen,
aber sozusagen mehrere Leute betroffen sind, aber vor allem er.
Und er war halt eigentlich immer so der Protégé von Selenskyj.
Und von daher Ja, war das sicherlich, wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen,
dass Zelensky davon nichts wusste, war das sicherlich eine große persönliche Enttäuschung.
Und Schaden soll wohl in der Größenordnung von 100 Millionen Dollar liegen an Kickbacks, sagen die.
Schon ordentlich. Ja, während das Land im Krieg ist und kein Strom hat,
kein guter Move irgendwie.
Ja, dann auch schon ein bisschen älter, aber ich wollte das nochmal erläutern,
weil das kriegt man ja sonst immer nicht so richtig mit.
Also es gab eine Änderung in dem Regime, wie jetzt mit Wehrpflichtigen in der
Ukraine umgegangen wird.
Zur Erinnerung, in der Ukraine wird man erst mit 25 Jahren eingezogen.
Es ist gesenkt worden von 27.
Mit anderen Worten, anders als in den meisten anderen Ländern zieht man die
Rekruten nicht mit 18 ein,
sondern man gibt ihnen quasi erstmal die Gelegenheit, so ein bisschen ihre Jugend
auszuleben und zu studieren vielleicht oder einen Beruf zu erlernen und dann
geht es erst ins Militär.
Das ist eigentlich ein interessanter Ansatz, wurde immer viel kritisiert von außen.
So nach dem Motto, ihr zieht ja
nicht euer ganzes Potenzial ran und an der anderen machen das ja auch so.
Andererseits ist das natürlich auch irgendwo moralisch ganz gut verortet, diese Regelung.
Ja, es hat halt so verschiedene Vor- und Nachteile für unterschiedliche Akteure.
Also die eine Sache ist, dass man natürlich so 18- oder 19-Jährige viel eher
um den Block scheuchen kann.
Das sind halt noch Jugendliche, die sind noch gewohnt von den Eltern.
Gesagt zu bekommen, was sie zu tun haben.
Das heißt, der Übergang dann ins Militär sorgt jetzt nicht für zu sehr Reibungen,
wenn du plötzlich dann wieder quasi lebst,
also wenig selbstbestimmt lebst, sondern quasi ja dann nochmal gehorchen musst.
Und ich habe das halt erlebt, dann später in den Wehrübungen,
wenn du so 25- bis 30-Jährige hast,
die dann deiner Truppe sind, das ist eine ganz andere Dynamik als unter 18-
oder 19-Jährigen, weil das Leute sind, die dann teilweise schon 10 Jahre im Beruf stehen.
Wir hatten dann unter anderem so, was ihr wisst, ein Bergmann,
29, der hat sich halt überhaupt nichts sagen lassen.
Er hat halt wirklich, ja.
Die ganze Wehrübung irgendwie zum Joke gemacht und wo wir dann auch teilweise
lachend in der Ecke lagen, wenn er,
kleine Anekdote, ganz kurz.
Aber dann so im Schützengraben und dann kommt der General zum Inspizieren und
alle mit Platzpatronen und so sitzt du dann da und dann kommt der General an und der Typ,
Vorher schon Mütze und dann ja, auf einmal sieht er den General und ruft halt,
und gibt so eine Salve Platzpatronen aus dem MG ab. Ist scheiße.
Aber der Sound ist einfach spitze.
Ich darf gerade mir alle... Er hatte selbst, der General hatte Schwierigkeiten,
seine Ruhe zu bewahren und wusste auch nicht, was er damit machen soll.
Also mit 25-Jährigen, da musst du dann schon ein bisschen sensibler möglicherweise rangehen.
Und weil ja die immer andere Aspekte,
Sind natürlich, dass das wirtschaftlich, wenn du das vor der Ausbildung machst,
kannst du sagen, ja, deren Arbeitskraft ist noch nicht so viel wert.
Aber wenn du dann jemanden mit 25 mitten aus dem Beruf rausholst,
der ausgebildet ist, dann ist rechnerisch eigentlich der wirtschaftliche Schaden
irgendwie potenziell größer oder die Umstände, macht mehr Umstände,
einen 25-Jährigen rauszuholen.
Aber wenn du natürlich im Krieg bist, wiederum Vorteil ist,
du hast dann möglicherweise nicht so
viele traumatisierte Jugendliche und wahrscheinlich auch ein Aspekt ist,
dass die möglicherweise vorher noch eine Familie gründen und Kinder zeugen können,
bevor sie dann eventuell an der Front dann...
Und das ist definitiv eins der offiziellen Argumente für diese Regelung.
Also das wird ja genauso gesagt.
Und ja, also das ist immer eine Abwägung. Ich meine im Prinzip ist das Einziehen
zum Militär ist halt generell eine Disruption. Die Frage ist,
was ist unterm Strich für dich besser?
Ukraine hat es halt jetzt so gemacht. Naja, worauf ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollte ist,
es gab bis vor einer Weile eine Regelung, wo eben potenzielle Wehrpflichtige,
wenn das dann eben auch erst mit 25 stattfindet.
Nicht ausreichen dürfen ab einem bestimmten Alter, also ich glaube ab 18 oder so.
Und dieses Alterslimit wurde jetzt auf 22 angehoben.
Das heißt bis zu 22 Jahren dürfen die Jugendlichen, also die potenziell später
Wehrpflichtigen, das Land wieder verlassen.
Das ist jetzt keine innenpolitische Diskussion, die ich jetzt besonders intensiv
verfolgt habe, sondern eher zur Kenntnis genommen habe.
Ich schätze mal, da war der Widerstand einfach zu groß, beziehungsweise man
wollte auch die Möglichkeit geben,
Erfahrungen im Ausland zu sammeln oder vielleicht auch Kontakt zu Familien zu
erhalten und damit sozusagen auch Rückkehr zu ermöglichen, weil das ja im Prinzip
auch so ein bisschen Amnestie für die, die dann trotzdem abgehauen sind, war.
Das ist also definitiv eine Regelung, die jetzt aktiv geworden ist und erlaubt
natürlich auch die Ausbildung im Ausland.
Also es ist natürlich auch so ein Aspekt, dass sie unter Umständen dadurch Leute
auch motivieren wollen, im Ausland Fähigkeiten zu erlernen, von denen die Ukraine
später profitieren kann.
Weil es jetzt ja auch nicht so ist, dass keiner mehr zurückkommt.
Am Ende haben die auch alle ihre kulturelle Verankerung in dem Land und wollen
es ja eigentlich gar nicht verlassen und haben dort Familie und Freunde.
Nicht alle flüchten dann sofort und deswegen ist es jetzt so.
Eine zweite Regelung, die eingeführt wurde, auch schon eine Weile her.
Das ist Dual Citizenship.
Eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft.
Genau, also sie erlauben eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft, was bisher so nicht die Regel war.
Und interessanterweise beginnt, es ist sozusagen limitiert auf bestimmte Länder.
Also es gilt nicht generell für alle Länder, bestimmt auch nicht für die russische.
Aber es erlaubt Dual Citizenship für dann Deutschland, Tschechien und Polen.
Und später soll wohl auch noch, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt mittlerweile erfolgt
ist, Kanada, USA folgen.
Und das geht both ways. Also es können sowohl Deutsche jetzt die ukrainische
Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen, als auch Ukrainer die Deutsche.
Ich schätze mal auch hier dürfte ein bisschen die Realität wieder mit reingespielt
haben, dass eben jetzt viele in diese Länder auch geflohen sind,
dort schon in irgendeiner Form heimisch geworden sind und es für sie ja auch
von Vorteil ist, dort die Staatsbürgerschaft anzunehmen,
aber die Ukraine sozusagen diese Leute auch nicht verlieren möchte und damit
durch eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft quasi best of both worlds hat.
Dadurch sind die Leute dem Land gegenüber nach wie vor verpflichtet und dem
Land gegenüber auch nach wie vor verbunden,
aber haben auch die Möglichkeit dort im Ausland und ich meine viele sind jetzt
eben im vierten Jahr dort und können potenziell halt schnell eingebürgert werden.
Polen sicherlich nochmal einfacher.
Ich glaube, in Deutschland ist es im Moment nach fünf Jahren,
wenn du fünf Jahre in Deutschland gelebt hast.
Weil die CDU das jetzt wieder geändert hat. Weil die Verkürzung,
glaube ich, die letzte Regierung eingeführt hat, auf drei Jahre wieder zurückgenommen
hat oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, also das ist auch noch so eine Regelung.
Ja, wobei in den USA die Debatte jetzt mal wieder aufkam, dort die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft abzuschaschen, was aber nicht passieren wird.
Das kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen. Allein wegen der ganzen Juden,
wegen der ganzen Israelis,
die halt dort, ja, Amerikaner mit israelischer Staatsbürgerschaft und so.
Und ja.
Auf das Trainbreak USA kommen wir noch.
So, Deutschland hat aber auch eine Änderung eingeführt nach langer,
langer Diskussion um eine neue Wehrpflicht oder um den Umgang mit einer ausgesetzten Wehrpflicht.
Gab es ja verschiedene Vorschläge von Pistorius, wie denn damit jetzt so umgegangen
werden soll und dann hat sich die Koalition halt da ordentlich in die Haare
bekommen über dieses Thema.
Und am Ende steht jetzt die Einführung, also nicht die Einführung oder nicht
die Reaktivierung der Wehrpflicht.
Also schon gar nicht in der alten Form, aber überhaupt in irgendeiner Form war
ja auch debattiert worden, ob man das wieder tun sollte.
Also die Wehrpflicht existiert auf dem Papier noch, bleibt aber ausgesetzt und
stattdessen wird jetzt die Musterung aber wieder eingeführt.
Aber ich glaube, die Regelung ist so, dass jetzt alle potenziell wehrpflichtigen
zwangsweise gemustert werden,
dass man zumindest eine Datenbank aufbaut und sagt, wäre im Prinzip tauglich
oder hat solche Eigenschaften etc.
Aber das hat dann erstmal keine Konsequenz. Also es führt nicht dazu,
dass man irgendwo verpflichtet wird oder eingeladen wird, sondern nur,
dass der Staat erstmal weiß, was haben wir denn überhaupt.
Ja,
ich meine.
Du bist ja mal gemustert worden, ich bin ja nie gemustert worden.
Ja, ich habe dann auch 15 Monate Wehrdienst geleistet.
Wie fandest du so Wehrpflicht so als Mensch mit doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft?
Ja, ich meine, erst mal war es natürlich ein bisschen kurios,
Ich dachte, ich muss nicht, weil ich auch eine zweite Staatsbürgerschaft habe,
die damals auch noch eine war, eben auf der anderen Seite des Zauns.
Ja, des Tauns, genau.
Also Tschechien, wer es nicht weiß. Tschechien, genau.
Weshalb die Tschechen mir, als ich dann da war mal, wurde ich dann quasi vom
tschechischen Geheimdienst vorgeladen.
Und ja, aber nur, die haben mir
dann nur erklärt, dass sie mich nicht zum Militärdienst einberufen werden.
Darum ging es dann, weiß nicht, warum die mich da extra vorgeladen haben,
aber sie meinten, sie hätten kein Interesse daran.
Haben sie auch gesagt, warum sie kein Interesse daran haben?
Naja,
Ich meine, da es der Geheimdienst war, also war halt klar, dass sie halt aus
Spionageabwehrgründen einfach nicht wollen, dass da jemand in ihrer Armee lient.
Und der so plus, es ist wohl auch so, also eigentlich auch völkerrechtlich ist es so geregelt,
dass wenn zwei Staaten Wehrpflicht haben, aber kein Abkommen über die Ableistung
des Wehrdienstes, also wer wo, je nachdem, das ist ein zwischenstaatlicher Abkommen,
wo heißt, okay, die Hälfte hier, die Hälfte da oder wenn dann nur bei uns.
Aber wenn es kein Abkommen gibt, dann ist die Regelung, dass man wehrpflichtig
ist in dem Land, wo man seinen ständigen Wohnsitz hat. Und das war bei mir Deutschland.
Und das war dann auch die deutsche Position bei der Musterung.
Die wurden ja hier.
Ja, das waren jetzt nicht. Ja, und ich meinte, und sie haben jetzt keine Bedenken,
dass ich da irgendwie was ausspähen würde oder irgendwie Informationen,
sagen, an meine Familie dort weitergebe oder im Ernstfall vielleicht Hemmungen habe,
sagen, auf Familienmitglieder zu schießen. so, nö.
Ist uns egal.
Ja, ist uns egal. Während in Tschechien waren sogar die,
Eisenbahnschienen, also die Pläne, wo die Eisenbahnschienen langlaufen,
waren Staatsgeheimnis.
Da hat Frau Kennedy dort dann gearbeitet hat und der dann vorgeworfen wollte, sozusagen,
irgendwie Spionage und so, weil die war halt auch Ausländerin und meinte dann auch dann,
in irgendeinem Gespräch platzte sie dann raus Ich werde dann sämtliche Eisenbahnpläne
an den Westen weiterleiten, dann wissen die, wo die Eisenbahnen sind,
dann müssen sie alle Eisenbahnschienen verlegen.
Um irgendwie so ein bisschen die Absurdität des Ganzen.
Also da gab es jedenfalls in Ost und West sehr unterschiedliche Bedenken,
was so den Wehrdienst angeht.
Aber die Frage, wie war es denn eigentlich,
Und meiner Meinung nach hätte es kürzer und intensiver sein können.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, da war eine ganze Menge Leerlauf.
Und ansonsten hatte ich meinen Spaß, so muss ich sagen.
Ich hatte dann auch gesagt, okay, wenn ich dann schon hin muss,
dann will ich aber auch alles mitnehmen und habe alles angekreuzt.
So was man ankreuzen konnte.
Was gab es denn da zum Ankreuzen?
Naja, zum Beispiel sprungwillig. So, ob ich bereit bin, irgendwie Fallschirmspringer zu werden.
Und weil ich das dann angekreuzt habe, nahmen die das dann auch gemacht.
Ich glaube, ich hatte auch Strahlflugzeugführer angekreuzt.
Also, wo sind Pilote?
Strahlflugzeugführer.
Ja, so nannte sich das.
Und ja, Fallschämiger war es dann. Und dann, ja, das war schon nett,
so dann mit Hubschraubern auch über Sauerland im Tiefflug so von einem Tal ins andere.
Und ja, dann, wie gesagt, aus dem Flugzeug auch zu springen.
Und gut, das war, irgendwann war ich da.
Also noch ein Ding zum militärischen Springen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man jetzt im Freifall und dann irgendwann eine
Reißleine zieht, sondern das ist eher so Massen absetzen.
Das heißt, du hängst die Reißleine, hängst du halt den Stahlseil ein und wenn du aus der Tür springst,
dann ist der eine Ende der Reißleine mit dem Flugzeug verbunden,
das andere Ende mit dem Fallschirm und zieht dann quasi den Fallschirm dann direkt raus.
Und hat dann so eine 50-Kilo-Schnur, also die bei 50 Kilo reißt und dann reißt das Ding ab.
Und dein Schirm ist sofort auf. Du musst halt nur gucken, dass du so aus dem
Flugzeug rauskommst, dass der Fallschirm hinten und du unten bist.
Und im Ernstfall ist es so, dass von dem Moment, wo du aus der Tür gehst,
bis du unten auf dem Boden aufsetzt, sieben Sekunden vergehen.
Sieben Sekunden aus der Tür bis am Boden so.
Tief fliegen die.
Ja im Ernstfall also wir beim Training haben wir ungefähr aus 300-400 Metern
Höhe gesprungen, da bist du dann so eine halbe Minute bis eine Minute.
Schwebst du da durch weswegen in den ganzen Filmen haben die das halt auch anders
gezeigt also ich meine wenn du es im Film siehst springen die Leute mit einer
Reserve Weil in Friedenszeiten und aber in Kriegszeiten ist es so,
springst du ohne Reservefallschirm und wirst ungefähr aus 100 bis 130 Metern Höhe abgesetzt.
Die ersten 50 Meter fällst du in drei bis vier Sekunden,
bevor der Schirm sich vollständig entfaltet hat und die weiteren 50 Meter,
du fällst da mit ungefähr 10 Metern pro Sekunde, sind dann nochmal weitere fünf
Sekunden, bis du auf dem Boden bist.
Wenn der Schirm nicht aufgeht, hättest du eh keine Zeit, die Reserve zu ziehen,
deswegen hast du dann im Ernstfall gar keine dabei.
Also ganz andere Art von Springen. Aber gut, kleiner Abstecher hier.
Aber insgesamt würde ich sagen, so für mich als abenteuerlistigen Jugendlichen,
der zu allerlei Schandtaten bereit war,
hat das schon Laune gemacht, dann mit geländegängigen Fahrzeugen da über die
Truppenübungsplätze zu heizen und so Dinge wie Unimog Weitsprung zu machen und so.
Und alles auf fremde Spritkosten.
Und die Mock Weitsprung? Ja.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe so, ja, weiß nicht, ungefähr etwas über eine Fahrzeug,
anderthalb Fahrzeuglängen habe ich ungefähr geschafft, so in der Luft zu bleiben.
Ist das Material für solche Belastungen ausgelegt?
Ja.
Gut, wir sind aber eigentlich bei der Musterung. Also du sagst, du hast durchaus Spaß.
Die Frage ist ja, wie denkst du jetzt über eine Neuregelung oder Wiedereinführung
der Wehrpflicht und vielleicht sagen wir auch nochmal kurz, was jetzt die Regelung
ist und dann vielleicht, wie sie auch sagen könnte.
Ja, vielleicht noch eine Sache.
Es gab mehrere Szenen auch, wo ich mir gesagt habe, in den Krieg möchte ich
mit dieser Truppe nicht ziehen.
Das vielleicht noch als Kaveat dazu.
Weil so eine Szene, wo sich irgendwie ein Fahrzeug festgefahren hatte und nachdem
dann Offiziere und Unteroffiziere,
das sind alles Experten im Auto fahren und so, aber nicht unbedingt in Physik,
so anderthalb Stunden später waren fünf Fahrzeuge festgefahren.
Ja, und ich konnte es sehen, weil ich meine, ich weiß nicht,
ich kann halt Physik, ich weiß halt, was passiert, nur irgendwie Kraft hier.
Das war so der Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, okay,
nee, lieber nicht, bloß nicht in den Krieg damit. Aber unser Job war ja auch
Abschreckung in erster Linie.
Also wir waren ja nicht zum Krieg führen da, sondern sollten nur so realistisch
wie möglich tun, als wenn wir in den Krieg ziehen würden oder könnten, wenn denn einer käme.
Und das hier ist natürlich eine ganz andere Situation. Also wenn es dann plötzlich
tatsächlich ernst wird.
Ja...
Aber grundsätzlich muss ich sagen, ist es mir sympathischer, eine Armee,
die auf Mitwirkung der Bevölkerung angewiesen ist, sage ich mal so,
als eine Berufsarmee, die es leichter macht,
Kriege zu führen.
Ja, weil in dem Moment, also eine Wehrpflichtarmee, glaube ich, der Hauptvorteil ist,
dass sie dann wirklich zwangsweise einen großen Teil defensiven Charakter hat
und dass sie nicht so einfach dann in der Lage bist,
irgendwo Krieg zu führen, während das mit einer Berufsarmee deutlich einfacher ist.
Ja, trotzdem hat man aber jetzt in Deutschland quasi Bedenken darüber,
dass man die notwendige Truppenstärke erreichen kann, beziehungsweise nicht
weiß, wie man fragen soll, wenn man eine Verstärkung braucht.
Ja, naja, ich meine, Deutschland ist groß im Vergleich zu vielen anderen NATO-Ländern
jetzt, die da sehr kleine Armeen haben.
Und Deutschland hat aber im Moment auch einfach ein winziges Militär,
somit deutlich im Moment unter 200.000.
Und so, das war, also ich habe mir mal angeguckt, wie das denn,
wie viel denn so eingezogen wurden.
Und als ich 1984 meinen Wehrdienst geleistet habe, waren ungefähr 200.000 pro
Jahr Wehrpflichtige, glaube ich, die eingezogen wurden für 15 Monate.
Und in der Hochphase davor waren es sogar bis zu 300.000 pro Jahr.
Zum Schluss, in der Endphase, so in 2011, wurden nur 20 bis 30 Prozent eines
Jahrgangs einberufen, so um die 100.000 im Jahr.
Und das ist natürlich das Problem, wenn du nur 20 bis 30 Prozent einberufst,
wo bleibt dann die Wehrgerechtigkeit? Warum muss der und der nicht?
Ja, so. Und, äh.
Ja, insofern wäre jetzt, also wenn ich das jetzt zu gestalten hätte,
ich würde tatsächlich jeden, der tauglich ist, würde ich einziehen und trainieren.
Also für, ich sage mal, mindestens sechs Monate ungefähr.
Ja,
und das Problem ist natürlich, ich würde auch Frauen mit einziehen,
so, Wehrdienst machen auch viele Länder, also Israel zum Beispiel kommt damit wunderbar klar, Ja,
wird aber in Deutschland, da müsste man Artikel 12 Grundgesetz ändern,
wenn man das machen wollte und Grundgesetzänderung, ja.
Immer schwierig.
Nee, so. Und ich meine, gerade auch jetzt, wenn wir gucken, was denn so moderne
Kriegsführung eigentlich bedeutet, da ist dann auch viel Technik,
Drohnenfliegen.
Also ich denke, wenn ich mir jetzt eine Regelung aussuchen könnte oder jetzt
einfach eine erlassen könnte, dann wäre das das.
Aber dann hat man natürlich das Problem, dass man dann plötzlich eine halbe Million Euro,
pro Jahr irgendwie unterbringen und ausbilden muss.
Wir hatten mal die Kapazitäten, aber die Kasernen sind alle zur Hälfte,
alle wegverkauft, umgebaut.
Und die Waffen und Lager und Uniformen, es ist nichts mehr da.
Das heißt, man müsste dann erst mal allein überhaupt investieren,
dass man dann für all die Leute plus.
Und dann macht es auch nur Sinn, wenn die Leute dann noch eine Weile current bleiben.
Also wenn du dann eine Reservistenarmee, also ich würde dann so wahrscheinlich
als Deutschland gucken, dass ich irgendwie zwei Millionen, drei Millionen irgendwie
sowas bewaffnen könnte.
So Reservisten einfach, die dann im Zweifelsfall zur Verfügung stehen.
Und das bedeutet dann natürlich auch in entsprechende Fahrzeugparks.
Also das wäre nicht billig, aber sagen wir, man hätte dann wieder eine stehende
Armee von wahrscheinlich 200.000 Berufssoldaten und 300.000 Wehrpflichtigen.
Eine halbe Million, die halt ständig da sind wie früher und die man dann auf
zwei oder drei Millionen ausweiten kann, wenn nötig.
Das wäre halt das Ding, wo man dann sicher sein kann, dass dann einfach...
Aber gut, ja, wird es so nicht werden.
Jetzt gibt es erstmal Musterung.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich auch ein, wie soll ich sagen.
Ist ja erstmal kein besonders scharfes Schwert.
Also dadurch, dass man gemustert wird, ist man ja erstmal zu nichts verpflichtet.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es sicherlich für manche auch ein Heranführungsmoment.
Einfach überhaupt erstmal diesen Kontakt zu haben und das kann ja sehr gut sein,
dass das allein schon mehr Leute motiviert aus eigenem Interesse oder eigener
Motivation eine Bundeswehrlaufbahn zu erwägen.
Das wird man dann erst sehen, von daher denke ich mal ist jetzt erstmal niemandem
nennenswert damit geschadet.
Lass uns mal wieder zurückkehren aufs internationale Parkett und bevor wir uns
auf jeden Fall nochmal mit Russland selbst beschäftigen und leider leider auch mit den USA,
wollte ich nochmal das Augenmerk auf Moldawien richten oder die Republik Moldau.
Wer die Geografie nicht mehr so ganz auf dem Zeiger hat,
Moldau liegt so im Westen oder im Südwesten der Ukraine,
ist quasi zwischen Ukraine und Rumänien eingebettet, ist ein relativ schmales
Land mit nicht sehr vielen Einwohnern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele, weißt du es gerade zufällig?
Ich weiß nicht, anderthalb, zwei Millionen irgendwie sowas in der Gegend.
Schauen wir mal, Republik Moldau laut Wikipedia hat...
2,4 Millionen ohne Transnistrien.
Und Transnistrien ist ja dieser Streifen im Osten der Republik,
der einen Großteil des Berührungspunktes mit der Ukraine einnimmt.
Im Norden und im Süden gibt es noch eine Verbindung direkt zur Ukraine,
aber Transnistrien ist so jenseits des Flusses.
Ich glaube, das heißt auch Transnistrien. Fluss heißt es irgendwie so.
Und ja, das ist halt ein nach wie vor im russischen Einfluss befindliches,
abtrünnige Republik, die nur von Russland anerkannt wird und die bisher ganz
gut davon gelebt hat, dass sie von Russland kostenlos Gas bezogen hat.
Und naja, da ging es dann auch immer recht grob daher,
da gibt es dann halt auch so ein paar oder vor allem ein großes Unternehmen,
was glaube ich so ein Großteil des gesamten Wirtschaftsbereichs des Landes so
ein bisschen in sich integriert hat, so ein Über-Amazon,
und den Namen jetzt gerade vergessen, aber da sind dann eben auch so diese Gelder
geparkt, die dann große Fußballclubs oder zumindest diesen einen Fußballclub
in Tiraspol da finanzieren und so weiter.
Naja, auf jeden Fall lief es jetzt nicht so gut für Transnistrien in letzter Zeit.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, Republik Moldau war natürlich auch extrem unter
russischem Propagandabeschuss, weil ja dort verschiedene Wahlen stattfanden
und das war vor vier Jahren schon mal der Fall.
Und jetzt gab es im September auch eine weitere Wahl.
Und bei der ersten Wahl 2021, da gewann eine pro-westliche Partei,
die hatte dort 52 Prozent,
also sie hat tatsächlich 26 Prozent zugewonnen in dieser Wahl.
Und ja, das war auf jeden Fall eine Abkehr von der Wahl zwei Jahre davor,
2019, wo noch eine pro-russische Partei stärkste Kraft war.
Und jetzt stellte sich eben die Frage, wird denn das halten mit dieser pro-westlichen
Einstellung und ja, die Antwort ist, hat gehalten.
Auch dort haben sie wieder die 50%-Marke überschritten mit 50,2% und man war
sich aber nicht so sicher, ob dem denn so sein würde, weil natürlich Russland
alles unternommen hat, um da propagandatechnisch in das Land reinzureichen.
Ja, das ist an sich sind das gute Nachrichten. Nicht so gute Nachrichten für
Transnistrien, wie schon erwähnt.
Diese Gaslieferungen, diese kostenlosen, die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr,
weil die Pipeline lief durch die Ukraine. Die Verträge der Ukraine sind ja nicht verlängert worden.
Das galt ja jetzt jahrelang noch im Krieg.
Das ist so absurd, aber so war es. Ukraine hat quasi den Vertrag,
den sie mit Russland hatten,
eingehalten, um russisches Gas in den Westen zu liefern und unter anderem eben nach Transnistrien,
aber dann haben sie diesen Vertrag nicht verlängert und dann gab es halt kein
Gas mehr über diese Leitung und Russland hat sich dann auch so ein bisschen
gebärdet, andere Wege zu finden, was vielleicht noch möglich gewesen wäre,
trotz alledem kam es nicht dazu.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, was diesen Move da so ausgelöst hat.
Auf jeden Fall steht jetzt Transnistrien nicht sonderlich gut da.
Und es wird auch gemunkelt, ob es denn hier Wege geben würde,
hier wieder zu einer Art Wiedervereinigung zu kommen.
Ich habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Also einerseits, ob es dazu kommt,
andererseits, ob es eine gute Idee wäre, wenn es dazu kommen könnte.
Weil Transnistrien wie auch ein paar autonome Gebiete im Süden Moldaus,
das sind jetzt alles bei 2,4 Millionen Einwohnern nicht viele Leute,
von denen wir hier reden, aber trotz alledem,
die haben nochmal so alte, andere kulturelle Bindungen, die halt mehr gegen
Russland zeigen als jetzt gegen Rumänien, wie das für den Rest der Republik gilt.
Ja, also ich war immer da und Moldawisch ist,
ich hatte schon gefragt, was denn der Unterschied jetzt zwischen der Moldawisch
und Rumänisch ist und ich meinte, es ist ein und dasselbe.
Die Sprache.
Meinst du jetzt.
Die Sprache jetzt die Sprache und,
Moldau gehörte früher auch mal zu Rumänien,
so deshalb das ist quasi ein Stück was sich Stalin irgendwie da von den Rumänen
dann einfach abgeknapst hat wenn man so ich glaube ja,
während ja jetzt Transnistrien tatsächlich sind glaube ich so eine halbe Million
Leute, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe und das sind,
ethnisch sehr unterschiedlich.
Viele Russen wurden da natürlich auch angesiedelt durch die Russifizierung,
aber ich glaube auch durchaus so,
Ukrainer,
leben dort und es waren da noch ja, ich glaube sogar polnische Männer.
Ein paar Deutsche sogar.
350.000 sind es übrigens.
350 sind es nur noch, ja. Und dann jeweils so Communities mit einigen 10.000
Leuten, die dann aus einer völlig anderen Gegend stammen.
Und insgesamt ist das halt wie so eine Karikatur von Stalin Russland.
So mit, ja,
also die haben sie dann Schlagbäume aufgebaut mit Sicherheit,
wenn rüber willst, während dann auf moldavischer Seite steht halt ein Typ,
der die Autos durchwinkt.
Und,
Ja, ja, und kyrinische Schrift und Hammer und Sichel im Wappen und so,
es ist alles so ein bisschen, so wird Union in klein gemacht.
Aber sie stehen halt jetzt wirtschaftlich nicht mehr so gut da,
werden jetzt auch energietechnisch vom Westen versorgt.
Und haben ungefähr 2000 russische Soldaten, die dort eines der größten Waffenlager
der Russen bewachen, ja noch dort. Das ist ja auch noch so ein...
Ohne dass Russland jetzt in irgendeiner Form eine Chance hätte,
dort eine Verstärkung zu erzielen.
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie die Russen dieses Land in irgendeiner Form
mit neuem Waffenmaterial versorgen wollen.
Also das geht nicht, die können nicht da rüberfliegen, also da werden sie nur
abgeschossen, es gibt keinen Seezugang, also das ist alles nicht möglich.
Und naja, also es wären also immer noch gut 100.000 Russischstämmige,
die man sich hier eintreten würde, würde es also zu einer Wiedervereinigung kommen.
Das ist halt die eine Position einer Wiedervereinigung, die andere Wiedervereinigung
oder Vereinigung überhaupt wäre halt die mit Rumänien, was quasi so der andere Weg ist.
Da muss man sich dann wiederum fragen, ob Rumänien sowas will und dann ist halt
auch damit ja Beitritt zur EU und wenn man aber in die EU will,
dann darf man natürlich keine geografischen Konflikte haben.
Also gibt es noch so einiges, was hier im Blick zu behalten ist.
Ich wollte das einfach auch nur mal erwähnen um zu sagen,
Moldau gibt es auch noch in diesem ganzen Spiel so wie die Ukraine hat auch
Moldau die Perspektive ja von der EU für einen Beitritt bekommen in die EU und
muss mal schauen, wie sich das,
dort weiter entwickelt.
Aber erstmal erfreulich oder zumindest nicht unerfreulicher als das war, was da vor sich geht.
So, jetzt schauen wir nochmal nach Russland und zwar Russlands Wirtschaft.
Wir haben es ja jetzt am Rande schon erwähnt, also insbesondere diese Angriffe
auf die Häfen, auf die Ölinfrastruktur etc.
Und wie natürlich auch die Kosten selbst des Krieges.
Also derzeit kostet nach Schätzung Außenstehender der Krieg Russland 2,7 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Das übersetzt sich derzeit in wie viel Euro? 3 Milliarden?
Nee, 2,5.
2,5 Milliarden, egal, immer noch eine große Zahl, 2,5 Milliarden Euro pro Woche. Pro Woche.
Also ungefähr 140 Milliarden im Jahr als US-Dollar.
Ja, aber das sind nur die direkten Kosten sozusagen, das was das Verteidigungsministerium
ausweist und das würde irgendwie 5% vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt vom russischen entsprechen.
Und das sind natürlich nur, wie gesagt,
die direkt zurechenbaren Kosten für jetzt Saldana und Waffen und also das,
was ins Budget des Verteidigungsministeriums fällt.
Und da sind dann jetzt eben andere Kosten, also jetzt die Subventionen der Rüstungsproduktion
oder gar wirtschaftliche Schäden, die durch den Krieg verursacht werden,
sind da jetzt nicht mit drin.
Und die indirekten Kosten sind kaum berechenbar, aber es ist klar,
dass sie ein Vielfaches davon betragen.
Also die Zahlen, die ich gehört habe,
sind bisher seit Beginn des Krieges nochmal 2400 Milliarden für Russland und
1600 Milliarden für den Rest der Welt,
was dieser Krieg jetzt an Schäden verursacht hat.
An teilweise ja höheren Kosten, an einfach geringerem Wirtschaftswachstum und
an mehr Friktion einfach, weil Transporte teurer werden.
Und Schäden an der Infrastruktur, ne?
Ja, das auch. Aber es ist mehr,
dass das Hauptding ist,
die eingeschränkte wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit oder das Umdirigieren in Russland
jetzt von Produktion von Gütern,
die dann weiter Wohlstand schaffen.
Oder also von Investitionen, die das Leben der Leute einfacher machen.
Das geht halt jetzt viel davon eben in Munition und in die Ukraine.
Und ja, wie gesagt, das trifft halt Russland in einem größeren Umfang als den Rest der Welt.
Also wir zahlen natürlich auch, also praktisch alle Länder irgendwie zahlen
mit für diesen Krieg jetzt, weil natürlich bei uns auch aufgerüstet wird und
wir Waffen liefern und so.
Unterstützen, aber auch, ja, wie gesagt.
Ja, es war allerdings gut.
Ja, also man merkt das also aus vielen Berichten, dass es also wirklich knarzt.
Es wird so rein buchhalterisch alles so ein bisschen auf die Regionen geschoben,
also Ausgaben für den Krieg werden so offiziell den Regionen dann zugeschustert.
Also zum Beispiel die ganzen Löhne und diese Ausgleichszahlung oder Startup-Zahlung für neue Rekruten,
die werden dann sozusagen von den Regionen bezahlt und indirekt gehört das natürlich
eigentlich auch zum Gesamtetat Russlands.
Mit anderen Worten, hier wird die ganze Zeit nur so eine Schuldenlast verteilt
und das bedeutet auch, dass jetzt diese Angebote, die Rekruten gemacht wird.
Nicht mehr so hoch sind, wie sie das noch vor einigen Zeit waren.
Das heißt, es wird jetzt weniger bezahlt, weil einfach nicht mehr gezahlt werden kann.
Das führt natürlich in zunehmendem Maße auch dazu, dass die Rekrutierungsziele,
die sie bisher hatten, so nicht mehr erreicht werden, so ohne weiteres.
Man muss jetzt glaube ich keine Illusionen machen, da sind immer noch eine ganze
Menge, die sich dort dann auf den Weg machen, aber potenziell ist das jetzt ein Segment,
wo es absehbar ist, dass Russland in zunehmendem Maße Schwierigkeiten bekommt
und wenn sie halt weiterhin ihre Leute an der Front so sehr verheizen,
wenn sie das Loch irgendwann nicht mehr stopfen können.
Das haben wir schon oft gesagt, sag ich gleich mal dazu.
Das war so ein bisschen von Anfang an unsere Vermutung, aber ich glaube wir
haben auch ein wenig unterschätzt, wie scheiße es den Leuten in vielen Regionen
Russlands geht, dass sie selbst so eine...
Eine Aussicht auf Tod in Kauf nehmen, um dann eben darüber Gelder einzunehmen,
zu denen sie sonst einfach keinen Zugang hätten.
Ja, also der Staat macht miese. Es waren jetzt irgendwie drei Quartale,
glaube ich, hintereinander stark im Minustendenz.
Es verschlimmert sich weiterhin, also es ist eine amtliche Rezession und diese
Situation führt halt dazu,
dass sie eben auch das Geld nicht mehr ohne weiteres ranholen können,
um im Ausland das zu kaufen, was sie brauchen.
Also Anleihen auszugeben, was ja Staaten normalerweise auch machen,
funktioniert hier auch nur noch sehr begrenzt, weil,
mal ehrlich, wer kauft russische Staatsanleihen, weil Anleihen kauft man halt
eigentlich, wenn man sagt so, ja, es ist ja vom Staat gedeckt,
das wird schon irgendwie hinhauern,
weißt du, mehr Sicherheit kannst du eigentlich nicht verlangen,
ist aber im Falle von Russland halt auch nicht so richtig mehr das Ding.
Und so sind sie dann gezwungen, Deals mit China zu machen, die dann in Yuan,
also in der chinesischen Währung, abgewickelt werden.
Das heißt, sie leihen sich da sozusagen Geld, aber das kriegen sie dann nur in Yuan.
Damit können sie dann wiederum Sachen in China kaufen, was sie teilweise halt brauchen.
Aber das belebt im Wesentlichen die chinesische Wirtschaft und ist kein guter Deal.
Und sie haben jetzt wohl auch eine größere Menge Gold verkauft an China.
Im Dezember ist es bekannt geworden für fast eine Milliarde,
im Wert von einer Milliarde Dollar Gold.
Und über den Rest des Jahres auch sozusagen verteilt irgendwie auch nochmal fast eine Milliarde,
also dass sie irgendwie größenordnungsmäßig zwei Milliarden an Gold an China verkauft haben,
was dann eben ja direkt aus Russlands Goldreserven natürlich rausgekommen ist.
Das sind jetzt nicht so gigantische Mengen, aber das zeigt sich halt auch an
der Stelle, dass sie jetzt, wie gesagt,
das ganze Jahr über so 100 Millionen im Monat und dann im Dezember jetzt plötzlich,
sagen wir nochmal, fast verdoppelt.
So, das wird Gründe haben, ja.
Mit der Rezession bist du sicher, dass das drei Quartale in Rezession sind?
Was jetzt klar ist, dass sie mindestens drei Quartale jetzt ein Haushaltsdefizit haben.
Ja, ist das nicht identisch?
Nee, Rezession ist, wenn die Wirtschaft schrumpft, also wenn das Bruttoinlandsprodukt schrumpft.
Und meiner Meinung nach sind sie immer noch im niedrigen Einstieg,
irgendwie ein bis zwei Prozent wächst die Wirtschaft schon in Russland. Ja, das ist das Problem.
Aber wir haben es jetzt klargestellt.
Ja, aber das größte Problem ist wahrscheinlich einfach,
das Wirtschaftsklima war ja ohnehin schon unter Putin nicht besonders gut und
du musstest als unabhängiger Unternehmer dann mit dem ganzen Korruption und wenn du Pech hattest,
hat dir einfach irgendjemand dann deine Firma weggenommen.
Über mithilfe korrupter Staatsbediensteter, wo du dann auch gesagt gekriegt
hast, du musst jetzt so und so viel Steuern zahlen und ja, dann,
wenn du das dann nicht gezahlt hast, haben sie dann einfach die Firma weggenommen und ja,
das dann an.
Putins Freunde weiterhin erreicht, die das dann profitabel haben, betreiben können.
Ja, ja, ja. Und jetzt aber natürlich,
wenn auch die Unternehmen dort sind natürlich auf Inputs angewiesen,
die sie bezahlen müssen und dann auf Arbeiter, die sie bezahlen müssen.
Und das können sie nur von den Einnahmen natürlich von dem, was sie produzieren
und wenn jetzt aber der Staat sie zwingt zum Beispiel unter Preis zu produzieren dann,
geht das auch nur so lange gut bis irgendwann,
bislang haben sie sich ja echt kreativ dann auch mit Hilfe jetzt der Staatsbanken
und mit ihrer Kriegskasse von 200 Milliarden und den Energieverkäufen und so halt irgendwie durch,
gemogelt, aber das geht eben auch nur eine gewisse Zeit lang und ja.
Und zu den Vorhersagen haben die gesagt,
am Anfang, ganz am Anfang, glaube ich,
in den ersten Monaten des Krieges mit den ganzen Sanktionen und so, das sah nicht so gut aus.
Aber dann seitdem war klar, okay, Russland ist jetzt nirgendwo in der Nähe eines Kollapses.
Das war klar.
Und wir haben auch gesagt, gut, aber dieses Jahr, so 2025, irgendwann geht das Geld aus.
Also die Art und Weise, wie sie sich bisher finanziert haben,
war klar, dass die 2025 es nicht mehr so weiter geht.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, auch gesagt.
Und jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt angekommen und haben dann auch gesagt,
dass sie es dann irgendwas anders machen müssen.
Also sie können nicht mehr so weitermachen. Sie müssen irgendwie andere Mittel und Wege finden.
Bis hin zu am Ende die Bevölkerung versklaven oder so.
Aber das ist nicht das, was Putin jetzt auch fahren kann, auch als Diktator
oder als autoritäres Regime. Aber...
Kannst du nur eine bestimmte Zeit so funktionieren, wenn du die richtigen Leute bei Laune hältst.
Und das scheint zunehmend schwieriger zu werden, jetzt die richtigen Leute bei Laune zu halten.
Aber wir werden sehen. Wir werden sehen.
Also die Aussichten sind auf jeden Fall nicht besonders gut.
Also durch ihre innere Wirtschaftspolitik und das Umstellen auf diese Kriegswirtschaft,
was ja dann wiederum die Gehälter hochgetrieben hat,
weil die Nachfrage nach Personal so groß ist, weil der Staat ist bereit sehr
viel Geld für Rekruten zu zahlen, also für Freiwillige im Krieg zu zahlen,
um sie überhaupt zu bekommen.
Dadurch stehen die ja wieder in Konkurrenz mit dem normalen Arbeitsmarkt.
Die Unternehmen bekommen die Leute nicht, beziehungsweise müssen dann selber
sehr viel höhere Gehälter zahlen, haben aber diese Einnahmen nicht.
Dann sind sie alle verschuldet. Die Zinsen sind extrem hoch.
Das heißt, die können auch keine Kredite aufnehmen.
Damit haben sie überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit, nennenswert zu investieren,
was dann halt auch nur eine bestimmte Zahl hochgeht.
Durch diese ganze Politik ist der Rubel aber dann irgendwie so künstlich hochgehalten,
was dann wiederum die Einnahmen senkt, die sie in den US-Dollar machen,
was im Wesentlichen ihre ganzen Einnahmen aus dem Ölgeschäft sind.
Und dieses Ölgeschäft selber ist für den Großteil ihres Haushalts zuständig
und sie haben in diesem Jahr im Wesentlichen mit Einnahmen von 70 Dollar pro Barrel gerechnet.
Wir haben ja vorhin schon berichtet. Derzeit sind wir bei der Hälfte davon. Und.
Wenn man weniger verkauft, dafür noch weniger bekommt und das ist der Großteil
deines Staatshaushalts,
dann lässt sich dieser Haushalt nicht so richtig füllen und dass sie jetzt schon
ihre eigenen Goldreserven nach China tragen, zeigt ja, dass sie quasi,
dass ihnen langsam die Optionen ausgehen.
Das heißt nicht, dass morgen schon alles vorbei ist, das heißt aber auch,
sie müssen sparen, wo sie nur können.
Jetzt ist zum Beispiel gerade bekannt geworden, dass so ein ambitioniertes Tunnelprojekt,
was sie eigentlich durchführen wollten oder zumindest davon geträumt haben,
das durchzuführen, eine Verbindung, eine direkte Straßenverbindung nach China zu schaffen,
weil also Russland und China sind zwar relativ nah beieinander und die haben
auch eine lange gemeinsame Grenze ganz tief im Osten,
aber dann kommt dann erstmal die Mongolei dazwischen und es gibt zwischen,
was ist das dann, Kasachstan und der Mongolei gibt es aber dann nochmal einen
ganz dünnen Streifen wo diese Länder miteinander verbunden sind,
also wo sie eine gemeinsame Grenze haben.
Das Problem ist, das ist eine extrem bergige Region.
Da kannst du nicht mal eben eine Straße durchbauen.
Deswegen hatten sie eigentlich vor, da mal einen fetten Tunnel durch den Berg
durchzutreiben, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie abgesagt, weil sie dafür einfach
nicht im Ansatz die Mittel haben, um sowas in irgendeiner Form vorantreiben zu können.
Und ja, Chinesen offensichtlich sind da auch nicht bereit, das alleine zu finanzieren.
Also ist das jetzt sozusagen durch.
Ja, sieht nicht so gut aus. Das Land wird auch immer repressiver,
insbesondere was das Internet angeht.
Also es gibt da jetzt so einen Staatsmessenger, den sie versuchen auf allen
Telefonen durchzudrücken, sperren in zunehmendem Maße andere Chat-Systeme,
damit also niemand mehr irgendwie im Geheimen chatten kann.
Da werden jetzt sogar Gaming-Plattformen abgeschaltet, um das entsprechend zu blockieren.
Also sieht alles irgendwie nicht so gut aus und wir werden das weiter im Blick
behalten, wie es Russland so geht.
Und wenn man es jetzt einfacher haben will, also so sagen Sie,
wenn der Ölpreis hoch war,
ist Russland einmarschiert und wenn der Ölpreis niedrig war,
dann mussten sie sich zurückziehen.
Also zumindest für Afghanistan passt das halt.
Also sie sind dann einmarschiert, da war der Ölpreis so um die 40 Dollar per Barrel, so in 1979.
Und dann zehn Jahre später, als sie sich zurückgezogen haben,
lag er bei 15 bis 18 Dollar per Barrel.
Ja, so, also in anderen Worten, wenn der Ölpreis zusammenbricht und ja,
ist Russland in der Regel gezwungen, sich zurückzuziehen.
Na, schauen wir mal.
Und wenn er steigt, dann überfallen sie andere Länder.
So ist ungefähr die vereinfachte Bauernregel, was so.
Ja.
Gut, jetzt wollte ich auch nochmal dein Tschechien-Expertenwissen abgreifen
und mal rausfinden, was denn eigentlich gerade in Tschechien-Scheiße läuft,
weil da gab es ja eine Wahl,
nicht die Wahl zum Präsidenten, aber die Wahl zum Parlament und da hat dann
wieder so ein Rechtsausleger gewonnen.
Ja, also ich habe mich mit der Wahl tatsächlich im Detail noch nicht beschäftigt.
Die vorherige Regierung war eine große Koalition aus fünf verschiedenen Parteien,
darunter die Piratenpartei.
Und da war es ein Wunder, dass sie überhaupt so lange,
durchgehalten haben, hauptsächlich, weil sie halt damals den Babisch nicht wollten und,
ja, jetzt ist er wieder irgendwie an die Macht gekommen,
aber Aber es war wahrscheinlich, weil irgendeine Partei aus der Koalition oder
insgesamt die Koalition dann nicht so beliebt war.
Aber es war vorher schon knapp.
Das heißt, ein paar Prozent können dazu geführt haben, dass er wieder an die Macht gekommen ist.
Sondern er ist halt eher so ein, ja,
oligarchisch.
Auf jeden Fall vertritt er dann so eine ähnliche Sichtweise wie der Fizo in
Slowakei und mit Einschränkung auch wie Orban in Ungarn.
Mag jetzt vielleicht nicht vom selben Kaliber sein, aber er hat auf jeden Fall
jetzt erstmal auch wieder gesagt, so ja, ne, Ukraine und so weiter.
Das ist ja alles viel zu teuer. Ich weiß nicht, für wie Russland gewandt hältst du ihn?
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht. Wie gesagt, er ist eher, wie gesagt,
Geschäftsmann, Oligarch.
Ja, das ist ja erstmal keine gute Nachricht heutzutage. Nee.
Und in anderen Worten, aber er ist auch so,
also er ist schon seine eigene Person. Also er ist jetzt nicht so jemand,
der dann durch Dritte einfach zu beeinflussen ist.
Das ist die eine Sache.
Die andere Sache ist.
Dass Tschechien aus historischen Gründen jetzt nicht so russlandfreundlich ist, sondern im Gegenteil.
Also es ist dann aus anderen Gründen wie Polen,
aber generell so 1968 ist nach wie vor im Bewusstsein der Tschechen und dann den so,
Insofern muss er da auch vorsichtig sein, wie weit er sich da jetzt aus dem Fenster lehnt.
Also in der Bevölkerung ist es nicht so wie in Ostdeutschland,
hast du halt einen Haufen Leute, die dann irgendwie russlandfreundlich sind,
so was er sich, Sarah Wagenknecht,
Und diese Art von Leuten findet man nicht so sehr in Tschechien.
Also was man dort auch findet, ist jetzt so mehr Ausländerfeindlichkeit und Rassismus.
Also das ist das übereinstimmende Moment jetzt mit Ostdeutschland und Tschechien.
Aber was Russland angeht, ja, Tschechien mögen die Russen einfach nicht.
Aber wie ist das Verhältnis von Tschechien gegenüber der Ukraine an sich?
Hat man da überhaupt eine traditionelle Verbindung in irgendeiner Form?
So wie Deutschland und Polen. Da kommen halt die billigen Handwerker und Bauarbeiter her.
Das war es dann auch schon, oder wie? Also man hat da jetzt keinen kulturellen
Kleister, keine Verbindung in irgendeiner Form?
Nee, das sind sozusagen aus tschechischer Sicht sind das die armen Nachbarn im Osten.
Okay.
Ach ja, das ist so schwierig in Europa.
Aber ich würde sagen generell eher positiv, Weil,
wie gesagt, die Ukrainer sind dort eher als fleißig und zuverlässig und belastbar
und beklagen oder beschweren sich nicht allzu sehr.
Und insofern ist das eher.
Vielleicht erklärst du noch mal kurz, wie ist das Machtverhältnis zwischen Präsident
und Ministerpräsident?
Also der Babic ist ja jetzt als Ministerpräsident gewählt worden,
es gibt aber nach wie vor den Petr Pavel, der Präsident ist,
war ja bestimmt welchen Teil der Politik.
Ja, also,
es ist halt vielleicht ein bisschen wie in Frankreich, also die Rolle,
das war nicht ganz, also es ist,
er hat mehr,
Mehr Befugnisse, so mehr Macht als jetzt der deutsche Bundespräsident,
der mehr oder weniger fast,
ausschließlich repräsentativ ist. ja, was er auf jeden Fall hat,
ist auch ein Veto-Recht, was so Gesetze angeht.
Wer hat das Veto?
Der Präsident. Aber das ist faktisch...
Wer bestimmt denn die Außenpolitik? Die Richtlinien der Außenpolitik.
Eigentlich auch, tja,
da bin ich tatsächlich nicht tief genug in der aktuellen tschechischen Politik drin.
Dann liefern wir das vielleicht später nochmal nach. Alright,
dann müssen wir jetzt zu dem hässlichen Thema kommen.
Ah. USA. USA.
Ja, es ist wirklich, ich finde es furchtbar. Deswegen lass uns da schnell durchgehen.
Also es ist ein Trainwreck, ist das einfach von Regierung.
Sehr deprimierend, ja.
Es ist alles ganz schön schlimm. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht groß über amerikanische Innenpolitik reden.
Das kriegen ja vielleicht die meisten Leute auch noch in irgendeiner Form mit.
Alles ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar und grauenhaft und faschistisch.
Und man kann nichts, man kann kein gutes Haar daran lassen. und leider ist es
halt auch auf dem internationalen Parkett und speziell im Verhältnis zu dem
Konflikt in der Ukraine nicht sehr viel anders.
Es gab ja immer mal wieder so kleine Hoffnungsschimmer, wo man dachte so,
okay, jetzt haben sich die Russen dann doch vielleicht mit Trump verscherzt
und jetzt geht er andere Wege, aber es zeigt sich eigentlich eher ein anderes Muster,
und das Muster würde ich mal ganz grob beschreiben als, Es werden immer Maßnahmen
gegen Russland ergriffen.
Wenn Trump einen neuen Hebel braucht,
um die Russen zu irgendwelchen Konzessionen zu zwingen, die für ihn gut sind und für seine Cronies,
aber nicht um irgendwie in irgendeiner Form einen Frieden und einen guten Ausgang
dieses Krieges zu finden.
Da gibt es einfach überhaupt gar keine Ansätze.
Und immer wenn man denkt, jetzt sind ja mal wieder Sanktionen erlassen worden
und das hilft ja jetzt auch mal wieder, dann gibt es meistens auch zumindest
in Teilen eine Rolle rückwärts und dann war es das.
Wir hatten ja diesen ganzen albernen Diskurs in Alaska, wo halt irgendwie nichts
bei rauskam und dieses ganze Gerede um Friedenspläne, da komme ich auch gleich nochmal drauf,
aber de facto findet nichts statt.
Also es gibt auch keinerlei militärische Unterstützung mehr in Form von Waffenlieferung,
die die USA selber bezahlen würde.
Sondern stattdessen erpresst man jetzt die Europäer in ihrer Notsituation und
zwingt sie eben diese Waffen in den USA zu kaufen.
Also zumindest die Waffen, die man eben derzeit in Europa nicht selber produzieren kann.
Das wird sich mittelfristig und langfristig auch ändern,
aber es gibt einfach bestimmte Systeme, die USA vorne und bestimmte Systeme
sind halt einfach erforderlich, wie zum Beispiel Patriot-Systeme etc.,
für die es überhaupt gar keinen technischen Ersatz gibt.
Dazu wird auch noch die Unterstützung der NATO immer weiter zurückgefahren,
Zusagen für die Unterstützung der Balken,
also finanzielle Zusagen für die Frontsicherung werden zurückgezogen.
Es ist halt einfach nur traurig, was dort stattfindet und wenn dann halt sogenannte
Verhandlungen geführt werden,
dann sieht das halt irgendwie so aus, dass er da seine Vertrauten zu Putin schickt,
die mit ihm irgendwas abkaspern.
Allen voran dieser Vollidiot Wittkopf,
der halt so ein alter Immobilien-Dude ist und so ein Golffreund von Trump,
der darüber hinaus auch noch so der Verwalter so seiner Krypto-Investments ist und ähnlicher Dinge.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist eigentlich eine reine Business-Beziehung,
die er hier als Außenpolitik verkauft und regelmäßig werden dann halt alle positiv
aufgenommenen Statements,
da hat er dann mal im Interview gesagt, ja ne,
Ukraine könnte ja auch die Gebiete wieder zurückerobern.
Das ist dann drei Tage später, ist das alles schon wieder überhaupt nicht mehr
so und dann heißt es so, ja nee, die Ukraine steht ja total schlecht da,
da sollten sie doch mal die Gebiete abtreten, das bringt doch jetzt eh alles irgendwie gar nichts.
Also zuletzt gab es halt dann diesen Friedensplan, den er dann aufgelegt hat,
das kommt halt immer mal wieder zwischendurch,
wo dann drin scheint, Ukraine soll Donbass und Krim abgeben und dann gibt es
angeblich ja so ein Ultimatum zum Thanksgiving, also es war vor diesem Thanksgiving
Termin, wann ist das immer? Ende Oktober.
Wo dann angeblich ja, jetzt müsste ja mal eine Entscheidung or else es werden dann immer solche.
Drohszenarien gemacht sonst ziehen wir uns hier komplett zurück am Ende gab
es einen großen Widerspruch von den Europäern von der Ukraine in gewisser Hinsicht auch,
wobei Zelensky das ja eigentlich immer ganz klug macht der lobt ja dann über
Trump immer, sagt ja, toll dass sie sich hier einsetzen und so weiter Da müssen
wir im Detail natürlich nochmal drüber reden, aber wie toll das doch ist.
Er weiß natürlich auch, wie man da mit Trump gut umgeht.
Das ist also an der Stelle vielleicht kein Trump-Flüsterer, aber er hat zumindest
gelernt, strategisch mit dieser Situation umzugehen.
Am Ende sagen sie natürlich so, ja, nee, aber Gebiete abtreten,
das können wir natürlich nicht machen.
Kommt natürlich dann am Ende wieder nichts bei raus und diese ganzen Deadlines,
die Trump immer ausruft, immer diese in zwei Wochen oder wann auch immer,
das spielt ja am Ende irgendwie keine Rolle.
Er wartet letzten Endes auf ein Angebot von den Russen und wenn die Russen sagen,
naja, dann machen wir halt hier ein bisschen Ausbeutung in Sibirien und dann
dürfen deine Freunde ihre Firmen vorschicken, dann läuft das.
Bestes Beispiel, diese Sanktionen, die jüngst ausgerufen wurden,
was ja an sich erstmal ein ganz guter Move war, die bedeutet haben,
dass halt so große Unternehmen wie Luke Oil.
Also Rosneft und so weiter, diese großen Öllieferanten in Russland,
die betreiben ja nicht nur in Russland Systeme und Anlagen, sondern halt auch außerhalb.
Im Irak, in Moldau und vielen anderen Ländern und auch in Deutschland war das ja so.
Ja, Rumänien, wahrscheinlich sogar Österreich, also wahrscheinlich in Europa.
Also verschiedenste Orte, wo so Ölraffinerien laufen oder andere Produktionsstätten,
die halt den Russen gehören.
Durch die Sanktionen wurden aber jetzt sozusagen die Bankgeschäfte eingeschränkt
und das hat dann diesen Ablegern die Möglichkeit entzogen weiterzuarbeiten.
Und dann gab es halt eine Deadline.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was aus dieser Deadline geworden ist.
Auf jeden Fall sind diese im Ausland betriebenen Organisationen gezwungen zu verkaufen.
Ich glaube, die wurde verlängert.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wurde wieder so eine Deadline, die einfach verlängert wurde.
Aber das ist sozusagen das Szenario gewesen eigentlich, was diese Sanktionen
an sich bewirken sollten.
Da sagen alle so, super, alles klar, dann müssen die Russen dann für geringes
Geld ihre ganzen Operations abgeben und dann ist das mal wieder unter der Kontrolle.
Dann kann ja Moldau das übernehmen, Transnistrien und so weiter und das dann
im Besitz dieser Produktionsstätten.
Und dann geht zwar ein bisschen Geld irgendwie an Luke Oil, aber das war es dann.
Und was kommt dann, dass dann in dem Moment, wo dann Unternehmen gesagt haben,
so ja, kein Problem, dann kaufen wir das halt, hat dann irgendwie Trump diese
Unternehmen dann wiederum bedroht, sie selber mit Sanktionen zu belegen.
Weil er möchte ja gerne, dass seine US-Freunde diese ganzen Assets kaufen,
damit das sozusagen alles in der Familie bleibt.
Also es ist einfach so ein einziges mafiöses Treiben, was dort abläuft.
Und wahrscheinlich sind viele Sachen,
viele korrupte Deals auch früher ohne Trump gelaufen, nur nicht so öffentlich.
Los und so in aller Öffentlichkeit und unter Beteiligung jetzt der US-Regierung
tatsächlich in dem Maß. Aber ich meine,
Das ist einfach absoluter Irrsinn.
Und da bleibt nur zu hoffen, dass irgendwann das Ganze wieder,
dass das Ganze aus oder dass viel davon einfach wieder zurückgerollt wird oder
aufgebereitet wird und Konsequenzen daraus gezogen werden.
Weil ansonsten, ja, sehe ich schwarz.
Ja, teilweise sind dann auch die Sanktionen, zum Beispiel bei Luke Oil,
auch wieder eingeschränkt worden, so still und heimlich.
Dann gibt es halt so diese Deals mit Belarus. Also dann hat er ja irgendwie
auch noch seine Cronies tatsächlich nach Weißrussland geschickt und dann mit
dem Lukaschenko Deals gemacht, was dann dazu geführt hat, dass Lukaschenko ja
so Dissidenten freigelassen hat.
Damit haben sie sich dann groß gebrüstet, so hier, wir haben ja irgendwie die
Friedensnobelpreisträger und so weiter alle frei bekommen.
Ja, okay, gut, das hat dann auch stattgefunden. Bloß der Deal war,
dass damit sich Belarus dann Ausnahmen von den Sanktionen erkauft hat,
sodass zum Beispiel Belarus erlaubt wird,
wieder Flugzeugteile zu kaufen im Westen, die natürlich, wie wir alle wissen,
hintenrum dann sofort weiter nach Russland geschoben werden,
damit die ihre zivile Flotte wieder auf den Vordermann bringen können.
Das ist dann halt wieder so ein Tit-for-Tat mit den Russen und so geht dieses
Spiel immer hin und her, damit er eben möglichst überall irgendwie seine Deals machen kann.
Mit Serbien läuft das genauso, da mit dem, wo sie jetzt stehen,
wo sie irgendwie so ein Gebäude, ein historisches Gebäude in der Stadt abreißen
wollen, damit dann irgendwie ein Trump Tower Hotel gebaut werden kann und so weiter.
Dieser Wittkopf ist aber der Schlimmste, der ja auch selber so ein bisschen
russische Abstimmungen hat und wie gesagt schon so ein bisschen der Kryptomanager von Trump ist.
Da ist jetzt irgendwie bekannt geworden, also erstmal, dass im Rahmen dieses
Friedensplans gibt es so Aufzeichnungen, so Kommunikationsaufzeichnungen,
wo also, so Audio war das glaube ich,
wo dann belegt wird, dass mehr oder weniger die Russen diesen Plan diktiert
haben, Also das so quasi nicht selber erarbeitet war, sondern er hat sich einfach
von den Russen so den Plan geben lassen, hier liest du das mal als Friedensplan
vor, das ist so das, womit wir leben können.
Was dann im Übrigen doppelt auch bestätigt wurde.
Einerseits eben durch diese Dialoge der Mitschnitte, wo man also klar ihnen
so, wo er dann gesagt hat, so ja, wie machen wir denn das so und die Russen
haben ihm das dann sozusagen erzählt.
Und auch in dem Wortlaut dieses Friedensplan gab es ja so sprachliche Analysen,
weil so bestimmte Formulierungen so ein bisschen.
Und dann sind Leute rübergegangen und haben gesagt, das ist wahrscheinlich so
eine KI-Übersetzung direkt aus dem Russischen, weil einfach so ein paar Formulierungen
so nur im Russischen gemacht werden.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall alles ganz furchtbar und man muss halt mal klar
einsehen, es wird keine Unterstützung der USA für die Ukraine geben in dieser Administration,
solange Trump der vorsteht und es wird auch für Europa an der Stelle keinerlei Hilfe geben.
Und deswegen müssen wir halt zusehen, dass wir uns von den USA so unabhängig
machen, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Das ist natürlich nichts, was du von heute auf morgen gebacken bekommst.
Das wird ein jahrzehntelanger Prozess sein, aber es muss halt einfach langsamer
klar sein, dass der einzuleiten ist, weil sonst wird es noch sehr unangenehm.
Sollte Russland in irgendeiner Form mal eine Verschnaufpause bekommen und auf
die Idee kommen, hier die baltischen Republiken auch noch hinzufügen.
Unter seine Fittiche zurückzubekommen. Und dann steht dann vielleicht eine NATO
da und Trump sagt so, ach ja, Letztland ist mir doch egal.
So, was soll's. Weil ohne die Amerikaner fehlen uns einfach wichtige Möglichkeiten,
wichtige Facilities und technische Fähigkeiten, um in irgendeiner Form einem
solchen Szenario sich entgegenzustellen.
Und auch wenn es vielleicht manche Leute als unwahrscheinlich ansehen, kann ich nur sagen,
der Einmarsch in die Ukraine, der wurde auch allgemein als unwahrscheinlich
angesehen, hat aber dann doch stattgefunden und mittlerweile haben wir es hier
mit einem Krieg zu tun, wo die,
Russen schon bald mehr Verluste und Zeit und Soldaten reinstecken als irgendwie
in den Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Und noch ein Aspekt, ich will mir gerade noch ein, Kaliningrad sieht es auch
nicht gut aus für die Russen.
Also da ist die Unzufriedenheit hoch, Wirtschaftsproduktion eingebrochen, so die Isolation.
Ich meine, die Leute dort waren es halt gewohnt, eigentlich in den Nachbarländern
einkaufen zu fahren und dort Zeit zu verbringen, zu studieren teilweise so.
Und jetzt sind sie da mehr oder weniger isoliert. Ganz viele Leute sind da weggezogen.
Kaliningrad selbst wird jetzt auch mit viel Geld am Leben erhalten und es ist
kein wirtschaftliches Asset mehr für Russland,
sondern nur noch die Militärbasis im Wesentlichen.
Ja, eine teure Militärbasis.
Na, da wird Trump sicherlich noch was einfallen, wie er den Russen da noch irgendwas
verkaufen kann, wenn sie da ein Problem haben.
Ja, ich wollte das nur mal so klar sagen. Also man braucht da nicht drauf zu schauen.
Das heißt, wenn es überhaupt einen politischen Prozess gibt,
der hier wirkt, dann ist es eine geeinte EU, haben wir aber leider auch nicht.
Und die einzigen Sanktionen, die derzeit gegen Russland wirklich greifen,
das sind sozusagen die Angriffe auf die Köln. Ja, die kinetischen Sanktionen der Ukraine.
Na gut, dann sollten wir es hier langsam mal zu Ende bringen,
vielleicht so mal mit einem generellen Ausblick, wie wir so die Situation sehen.
Weil es ist ein bisschen immer schwierig,
sich in diesem Gewirr von Details da noch ein Bild zu machen vielleicht,
auch wenn wir natürlich hoffen, dass wir jetzt durch die Schilderung all dieser
Details bei euch ein klareres Bild erzeugt haben.
Ich würde es mal so zusammenfassen.
Erstmal, derzeit kann die Ukraine im Wesentlichen dem Druck Russlands standhalten.
Mit großen Verlusten, unter großen Entbehrungen, großen Tragödien und Schmerzen.
Die auch teilweise daher rühren, dass sich das Land einfach nicht ausreichend unterstützt sieht.
Nicht in dem Maße, wie es sein könnte und wie es auch sein sollte.
Trotz alledem ist die Resilienz dieses Landes nach wie vor ungebrochen und die
werden einen Teufel tun und den Russen irgendwas auf dem Silbertablett zu servieren.
Russland wiederum muss immer mehr Aufwand betreiben für immer geringere Ergebnisse in diesem Krieg.
Wir haben es ja hier ausreichend geschildert. Also finanziell,
humanitär, in jeder Hinsicht die Kosten steigen und es ist eigentlich kein Pfad
da für Russland in irgendeiner Form zu gewinnen.
Man spielt nur auf Zeit und das funktioniert nur wegen Trump.
Hätten wir eine andere Regierung in den USA bekommen, hätte Trump nicht gewonnen,
dann wäre, das sage ich jetzt mal so, dieser Krieg bereits zu Ende.
Ist er aber nicht. Die EU kriegt den Arsch immer nur so weit hoch,
dass er gerade mal nicht auf dem Asphalt schleift.
Also so eine gemeinsame Außenpolitik ist irgendwie immer noch ein Wunschtraum,
da ist immer noch alles von nationalen Interessen geprägt und das Orbán- und
Vizeproblem ist nochmal ein Thema für sich, wo ich hoffe,
dass das sich vielleicht mit den Wahlen im nächsten Frühjahr mal ändert.
Aber nicht zu viel hoffen. Erstmal gucken, was passiert.
Russland ist wirtschaftlich in zunehmendem Maße am Ende.
Der einzige Gewinner in dieser ganzen Situation derzeit ist eigentlich nur China
und vielleicht noch Trump und seine Cronies, aber wie lange das hält.
Das ist eine andere Sache. Aber nicht die USA.
Nee, bestimmt nicht.
Ja, ich meine, es ist so, fürs nächste Jahr ist das Budget da für die Ukraine, um Krieg zu führen.
Das hat ja jetzt Glück noch geklappt. Also sozusagen für die nächsten zwei.
Drei Jahre, zwei Jahre mindestens.
Ja, also jedenfalls so, also fürs nächste Jahr scheint irgendwie gesichert zu
sein, was die Ukraine angeht.
Und Russland wird sich jetzt was Neues einfallen lassen müssen.
Und immer wenn man sich was Neues einfallen lassen muss, ist die Frage, wie,
Ja, ist das erfolgreich. Das ist immer mit einem Risiko verbunden.
Und insofern besteht für Russland das Risiko, dass was auch immer sie sich Neues
jetzt einfallen lassen,
dass da irgendwas gravierend schief geht bei oder sie noch mehr unter Druck geraten.
Aber es kann sein, also bisher haben sich ja immer aus der Affäre gezogen irgendwie
in den letzten Jahren, immer wenn es unschön wurde.
Und insofern bleibt es abzuwarten, ob Russland jetzt weiter schwere Fehler macht.
Ich meine, einen Fehler zum Glück machen sie halt ständig, dass sie keine Reserven
aufbauen, sich keine Verschnaufpause gönnen.
Das ist mir ein bisschen unklar, aber das Problem könnte sein,
dass Putin einmal aufhört mit dem Krieg, dass er Angst hat, dass er dann nicht wieder anfangen kann.
Dass dann die Bevölkerung nicht mitmacht.
Das ist vielleicht für Putin der Grund, warum er nicht stoppen kann.
Auf der anderen Seite, oder sich einbildet, nicht stoppen zu können.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich Russland wäre,
Ich hätte halt das mit dem Waffenstillstand erstmal angenommen und hätte dann
ein halbes Jahr lang einfach mal Reserven aufgebaut und mich konsolidiert und
ein riesiges Arsenal wieder geschaffen.
Gut, könnte die Ukraine natürlich...
Natürlich auch aufrüsten und ausbauen. Insofern wird sich das dann vielleicht neutralisieren.
Auf der anderen Seite ist Russland dreimal so groß und mächtig wie die Ukraine grundsätzlich so.
Und insofern, ja.
Wir sagen dadurch, dass Russland halt schlecht ausgebildete, schlecht ausgerüstete.
Rekruten sofort an die Front wirft und dann sogar mit, ja, wenn ich erwähnt,
den Kavallerieangriff, ich weiß nicht, ob du gehört hast, tatsächlich mit Pferden oder so.
Mit Pferd einen Russe versucht hat, dann die ukrainischen Linien zu durchbrechen
oder was auch immer und das Das ist dann nicht gut gegangen.
Ich meine, das ist einfach Irrsinn.
Also es ist irrsinnig die Art und Weise, wie Russland Krieg führt.
Und wir können nur froh sein,
dass sie offenbar nach Regeln kämpfen und arbeiten,
die so irrsinnig sind und sich damit halt auch die ganze Zeit selbst im Weg stehen.
Das ist mein Gefühl.
Also insofern kein baldiges Ende in Sicht,
sondern es sieht eher so aus, dass wir jetzt ins fünfte Jahr gehen werden und
dann wahrscheinlich eher Mitte des Jahres wissen werden,
wohin der Zug geht.
Also im Moment ist es nach wie vor unentschieden.
Ja, ich würde sagen, an der Stelle machen wir mal einen Punkt hier.
Das war also unsere romantische Weihnachtsausgabe zum Krieg.
Ich weiß, hier gab dir immer richtig schön geilen Themen.
Frohes Fest und guten Rutsch so an alle, auch die das jetzt noch rechtzeitig hören.
Ja, überlegt mal, ob er auch die Ukraine in irgendeiner Form mit Spenden noch bedenkt.
Die können es auf jeden Fall ganz gut gebrauchen und ja,
das ist jetzt auch, glaube ich, mal dann so der letzte Podcast,
den ich dieses Jahr veröffentlichen werde und dann sind wir uns im nächsten Jahr wieder und,
bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.